Four three,
two,
one,
ladies and gentlemen.
Jeff Novitsky.
How are you buddy?
What's up Joelle?
Doing good.
I have to ask you,
do you mind the nickname
the golden snitch?
So first thing I was gonna bring up
this golden snitch bullshit.
I just want to say,
it's not my nickname.
It's Brennan jobs.
He came up with it 100% on his own.
He was going to ask you.
It's all good though.
It's good.
It's all good.
So a couple of funny stories about that.
So when did he come up with this?
About a year ago at least.
So,
so people in the office
started coming up to me saying,
hey,
golden snitch,
what the hell's that?
Do a little research as she,
something about Harry Potter
or some character named there.
I'm like,
what the hell does this
have to do with me?
So about a month ago,
somebody lets me know,
hey,
checkout Wikipedia.
So for whatever reason there's
a Jeff Novitsky Wiki pdf page.
You go to that page now it's so says,
actually my formal name,
Jeffrey John Novitsky,
Aka the golden snitch.
So last week,
Donna Marceline,
you know,
Donna,
um,
long 15 year employee of the UFC now
works with me and talk about her little
later.
It's a great asset to what we're doing.
She sends me a text,
she says,
check this out.
So she's got one of those Amazon Echos.
Um,
Alexa,
I think so.
She says Alexa,
who's Jeff Novitsky and
Alexis name says Jeffery.
John Novitsky Aka the golden snitch.
So thanks a lot.
Shop.
Oh,
shove.
What have you done?
That's hilarious.
I love Donna.
She's amazing.
She's awesome.
So she's over there.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know about kind of her history.
She was more of the five original ploys
of the UFC was Dana as assistant to
start out with,
uh,
went on to become VP of event operations.
So basically,
you know,
she got everybody to the event
set up hotel at the event,
ran the crew,
you know,
the blue shirts backstage
that run the event.
Um,
you know,
I think after doing it for many years,
she got a little burnt out on it.
So when to Dana,
uh,
mid summer and says,
look,
I don't think I want to do this anymore,
but I'd really love to do something else
and I've seen kind of what Jeff's doing
in his program.
I really like to go over there and
work with him and kind of learn,
you know,
what he's doing.
And so Dana pulled me
into the office and said,
Hey,
what do you think about this idea?
And it took me literally a half
second to say 100% on board.
This woman,
I mean,
as you probably know,
is about as attention to detail and
passionate about her work as anybody.
And really my positioning,
unlike the name,
the Golden Snitch,
is an advocate to our athletes to make
sure our athletes are successful under
the program.
Not that they fail under the program.
It's definitely the wrong nickname.
It's just catchy.
It is just unfortunately catchy.
Again,
I'm all,
I'm all good with it.
I back.
But,
uh,
the real golden snitches,
Victor Conti,
he's the Golden Snitch,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
I was actually,
I can see that because he was a
guy who was giving guys steroids.
You were a guy that was
always catching people.
Correct.
So it's the wrong moniker.
Giving them steroids and
then talking about it after,
right?
Yeah.
That's a snitch.
That's the golden stitch.
Not you man,
but it's all good.
I was hoping shop with him,
call him.
I'm up later in this show what
I could do anything to them,
but it'd be interesting to
look at him in the face.
He would say,
I'm sorry Bro.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
back to Donna.
She's awesome.
Um,
so I'm super psyched that she's with you.
So what exactly does she do for you guys?
Again her,
you know,
when I sat her down in the summer I said,
look,
your role here is going to make sure that
the athletes are successful under the
program.
And in a program like this,
there are so many landmines,
you know,
whether it be making sure your
whereabouts filing is that Tom is on time,
making sure you sought a,
knows where you're at so they can come
do a collection from you at any time.
Uh,
making sure you make
safe supplement choices,
making sure the medications
you're taking are correct.
So she,
you know,
works hard for all those things.
I give you the prime example of
what she brings to this program.
So every three months,
every quarter,
every single athlete on the roster is
required to file what's called quarterly.
Whereabouts.
Can I pause right here?
It does.
Just so this can be a standalone if
people don't know exactly what you do.
Sure.
Jeff is in charge of making sure that all
the UFC athletes are clean and free of
performance enhancing substances.
And it was a huge issue
before you came along.
A huge issue in the sport.
And,
and continues to be in
other organizations,
particularly overseas.
I mean there's just ramping speculation
about companies that literally encourage
people to take steroids.
It was always the case
with pride in Japan.
That was one of the big things
about pride ensin anyway,
who fought for them many times came on
the podcast and literally was saying in
the contract and like capital letters,
it says we will not test you for steroids.
Like they wanted everybody
to take steroids.
They,
I had friends who went
to fight over there.
They told him to take steroids
and move up a weight class.
So it was always an issue in the sport
that this was a dirty sport air quotes.
Right.
Yeah.
Um,
but since you've come along and since
you guys started instituting this
incredibly strict testing,
we've seen some pretty radical changes.
We've seen some amazing fights and
amazing performances and I don't think the
performance levels dropped.
In fact,
I think it escalated and elevated rather,
which is something that people
were really concerned about.
But one thing that we did see is some
people that you suspected of doing stuff,
their bodies radically changed.
It was really mean.
That became a meme pre
Usada and post Usada I mean,
and there's some comedy memes
out there because of it,
because people's bodies
change so radically.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
You know,
the last time I was on,
we talked about kind of the smell test,
looking at somebody and you know,
it's difficult to say
definitively whether or not,
you know,
changes
in bodies are due to that or not,
but you know,
you can't help but look at some of these
pictures before and after you saw it.
And I think that's the case.
That's something I always struggle with.
How do you judge the success of a program?
Um,
you know,
do you judge it on
numbers of positive tests?
I don't think that's necessarily the case.
You know,
maybe,
maybe you're not catching everybody.
Maybe there's no one to catch.
Um,
do you judge it on before
and after pictures?
I don't know.
I mean that,
that could be one factor.
I like to judge it a lot anecdotally.
You know,
a big part of my job is getting out
and building relationships with our
fighters,
with managers,
with coaches,
and just,
you know,
chewing on their ear and figuring out
what they're seeing and what they're
hearing.
And almost universally,
the feedback I get from,
from them is this is
making a big difference.
Um,
you know,
one thing I brought with me today,
and really the coolest piece of data
I think I've seen in any anti-doping
program are some really
objective measurable statistics
and the UFC anti-doping
program Usada so you saw it as the
United States antidoping agency.
They're the official antidoping agency
of the United States by an act of
Congress.
They're in charge of all drug
testing for us Olympic sports.
Uh,
back in 2015 we made the
decision to outsource the
administration of our program
to Usada.
The primary reason being
the independence factor.
Um,
you know,
when you look at all these other
professional sports league,
some have,
you know,
better programs and other none
really have any independence in the
administration.
That program.
And with that means is there's
no way of telling whether or not,
um,
you know,
when an athlete is sanctioned,
it's done for business reasons
or done for favoritism.
So in our program,
you know,
no one can say that that any of the
administration of our program has done for
that reason.
It's a truly independent authority.
So what you saw it did recently as they
went back and they'd been in existence
since I think about 2001
on the US Olympic level.
They went back and took a look at every
single doper I think for steroids.
Everyone was caught for steroids in the
existence of the Usada program and took
a look at each of those athletes,
biological passports and
biological markers and they
looked at what was the most
common factor for the
doper versus you know,
the non doper.
And what they determined was what stood
out the most was large variance in
testosterone excretion in the urine.
And we think about it,
common sense point of view that kind of
makes sense and that someone who's using
steroids at that time presents a sample.
Their testosterone excretion is
probably going to be on the higher end.
And if they were to catch
a doper on and off cycle,
what happens when you get off steroids
is your body suppresses production of
testosterone.
So in that case you're going to see
a very low excretion of testosterone.
So they looked at that and
plotted it out and saw hey,
every dope or has a very large
variance and testosterone excretion.
Then what they did is they took all the
UFC samples and they plotted amount by
quarter and actually brought
a graph along with me.
And it's some really drastic,
I think,
visual evidence of the success
and the impact of this program.
I don't know if you can throw
it up mom to take a look at it.
Um,
so when,
what year exactly did,
uh,
you saw a takeover?
Yeah.
So we can't,
you saw it,
it came into play July of 2015 so if
you saw it has been in existence for two
years.
So you see here,
um,
that first quarter,
quarter three of 2015,
a pretty decent variants there.
Um,
which means in any given test and athlete,
you know,
I was up on an average,
a little bit 30,
I'm a little,
you know,
in the mid twenties.
And then look at,
as you plot out that graph,
uh,
that variance becomes smaller and smaller
and smaller and more in the medium
range as it gets out to,
you know,
quarter three of 2017.
That's very interesting.
You don't,
you don't,
this is,
you don't usually see statistics.
This is the first I've been involved in
anti-doping world since 2002 and I can
unequivocally say that this
is the strongest visual,
objective,
measurable evidence of success
of a program that I've ever seen.
Well,
one of the things that's
so fascinating about this,
and um,
this,
this goes to this,
goes to credit to the UFC 100% is that
they decided to do something about this.
They didn't have to,
it wasn't like someone
coming after them because,
uh,
you know,
so many people had been
caught and someone said,
hey,
we're going to put a program on you
guys to make sure you're not doping.
Or the UFC said,
we've got to clean this up and there's,
there's only one way.
The one way is to go with the very best
testing possible and the most rigorous,
the most,
I mean checkin everywhere you go,
we're going to give you random tests,
six o'clock in the morning,
knock on your door,
like the whole,
the whole full gamut of tests and
the results have been pretty amazing.
And that alones that speaks volumes
when you see this size of the variance
between the,
uh,
the test when you guys first
started versus now definitely,
hey,
it's a credit to two people,
the Renzo for Tita and Dana white that
made that decision and that's a hell of a
risky decision but done
for all the right reasons.
You know,
anybody that contends that Dana doesn't
care about his athletes need look no
further than this program.
This program is of tremendous risk to
the company and to the bottom line.
When you're test athletes 365 days a year
on announced no predictability of when
the test is coming,
there can be some very severe
consequences to have been there.
Several main events there has been,
I mean,
UFC 200,
yeah,
the land,
arguably the landmark event
in the history of the UFC.
We lose our main event,
the before
UFC 200 millions if not tens of
millions into the marketing of that.
Um,
you know,
the success of the paper view probably
hinges on that great main event between
John and Daniel and we lost
it three or four days before.
And that could happen.
Didn't you know,
at any given moment.
Now we talked about
this before the podcast,
um,
what you could or could not talk about
what the current state of John Jones
investigation.
So where's it at right now?
Yeah.
So,
you know,
generally we don't talk about,
uh,
the case.
So,
so how the process works.
When an athlete test positive
you sought it will notify me.
Um,
I usually pick the phone up right away
and call Dana and let him know and the
UFC puts out an announcement.
They say,
you know,
in the case of John John tested positive,
uh,
then in an in competition
test on this date,
um,
you know,
more information will be provided.
At the appropriate time.
That's generally all we'll talk about.
Now.
If the athlete chooses to talk about,
you know,
scenarios of,
of what happened,
then they're free to do that.
Um,
at that point you saw it in
the UFC can comment on it.
So there's been some things
talked about in the John Case,
uh,
by John.
Um,
particularly he had to clean tests on
July 7th and July 8th before his positive
test on I think July 30th,
which was way in day.
And the positive test was for to hydro
chloral methyl testosterone or oral
Terenna ball.
Um,
this is a substance that was
used by the East Germans.
I'm regularly in the late sixties,
and then came into the
fold a little bit more,
um,
of what's come out recently
a matter of Russia.
So,
um,
I know you had a Bryan Fogel on for,
for the ICARUS moving.
I think you talked about
a little bit about this.
Um,
uh,
Gregory,
the head of the Moscow,
a laboratory that this drug became
kind of part of his protocol,
um,
with his athletes.
He then ironically enough developed a
test for the longterm metabolites of the
drug.
So previous to that,
the detection window of this
drug was a couple of days.
So it was a drug that you know,
even if you run a strict program,
an athlete may gamble with taking because
it had a quick clearance time after he
discovered the longterm metabolite test
that changed and went from a detect and
when detection window of a couple of
days to a detection window of several
months.
And this was widely known,
you know,
it wasn't a secret.
Initially they kept it quiet and they
went back and retested some samples and
there was a whole bunch of positives and
then it got out 2013 around that there
was this new test.
So right up front,
you know,
I've,
I've said this a while now is,
would not make a lot of
sense for an individual,
a UFC athlete that new,
you know,
especially,
a champion contender like Jon Jones at
new and I'm tested quite regularly in
this program,
would not make a lot of sense that
that would be your drug of choice.
If you were intentionally trying to cheat,
um,
I think it's come out after the fact that,
uh,
you saw the,
did another test on John a month or two
or a couple months after his positive
tests and he was negative
during that test.
So that would be indicative that,
you know,
the prohibited system entered his system
or the prohibited substance entered his
system,
you know,
sometime after July 7th
or eighth and was likely,
you know,
a pretty small amount in that it
cleared his system pretty quickly.
Um,
again,
you know,
who knows where it plays out,
but certainly on the surface
of things I have said,
you know,
at this point in the game with
that type of information out there,
um,
it wouldn't indicate the intentional use.
Now that could be wrong.
I don't know that definitively.
And,
and we'll see how this plays out.
Uh,
right now where the process is as John
and you saw that are working closely,
um,
I'm aware that there was a
meeting a week or two ago,
pretty lengthy meeting,
which,
uh,
I was told was productive.
It wasn't given details
of what productive meant.
Um,
but I think that's an
important thing right now.
And that John's falling through with
his to retrace all of his steps between
that,
you know,
last July 8th positive tests and our
negative tests and the positive test on
July 29th of July 30th.
It certainly seems like,
based on what you just said,
that this is something that
was accidentally taken,
but if you can't prove that
something was accidentally taken,
like if you can't nail it down,
what do you,
what happens there?
Yeah,
it's,
it's difficult and that's,
you know,
that's kind of the nightmare
scenario that a lot of,
you know,
that an athlete can face in a big roll
of what Donna and I do to prevent that
from happening,
to show them what type of care and
consideration is needed to make sure you
don't get into a scenario like that.
You know,
under a program like this,
you have to be careful about everything
that's put into your body and
everything.
And,
uh,
if you're not,
there can be,
you know,
severe consequences.
Um,
so yeah,
we'll,
we'll see where this plays out.
I tell you,
the one thing that I,
that I can say about this is,
you know,
this is obviously John's second time I'm
in the program with testing positive.
And in the first time he went
through a pretty lengthy,
um,
appeal process and there was
a publicly issued a decision,
50,
60 pages that went through
all the evidence that,
that the independent,
um,
uh,
arbitrators heard and decided on.
And what they said definitively
in that case was John,
there was no evidence of
John intentionally cheated,
however he operated with careless,
reckless disregard.
Um,
so we ended up getting
the maximum for that,
for those substances you
tested positive for a year.
And that was for some gas
station Viagara type shit,
not well,
it was actually a couple
of anti estrogen drugs.
But what was shown and what the evidence
pointed to was that he took a pill that
was manufactured from a website by
the name of all American peptide.
Uh,
the pill was reported to be a Cialis pill.
So when erectile dysfunction pill
that was tainted with these two drugs.
Now,
the problem with the arbitrator said is
if he would have gone to that website
and the arbitrators did and I did,
you would have seen that
that same website offered,
you know,
tons of performance enhanced,
prohibited performance enhancing drugs.
And the website said,
you know,
not for human consumption,
for research purposes only.
So it really was careless
disregard that being said.
However,
John's,
you know,
second time through the program now
the second sanction this time for,
you know,
an anabolic type steroid would have,
a starting point potentially
have a four year suspension.
That's a starting point that
that could be a starting point,
right?
Unless there are mitigating factors.
Now I don't,
you know,
again,
the beauty of this program is it's not
the UFC or not me deciding what the
sanctions going to be.
No one can accuse us of,
you know,
operating for business purposes
or favoritism or whatever.
Um,
but that being said,
you know,
when we put this program
together and figure it out,
you know,
what sanctioning would look like.
I don't necessarily think that
we put up a four year sanction,
uh,
for a second term offense when the
first term of fence was shown that that
person didn't cheat,
intentionally,
just operated with careless disregard.
So who makes that distinction then?
You saw the shotgun,
makes that distinction.
They,
you know,
they have a whole team looking at it.
They compare it to other
cases under the Wada,
uh,
Olympic type umbrella,
similar cases.
Um,
I will say this,
that,
you know,
I think we've had a few over 60,
um,
positive adverse events in this case
and those that have been adjudicated.
I've been comfortable every time that
they've made a fair and balanced and
reasonable decision.
And that's part of my job is to be the
eyes and ears for athletes to make sure
not only is the program being
administered properly and has strength,
but also that they're being treated
fairly and that they have due process.
So I have all the confidence in the world.
However,
this does come out that it
will be the right decision.
The other really cool thing about the
program is the transparency the program.
So,
you know,
it won't just be me saying this,
however it does come out,
whether it goes to arbitration or
whether John and you sought or reach a
settlement,
it'll be well spelled out
about why that sanction,
uh,
was determined.
Now you say starting point,
meaning that it could potentially be more,
it could.
So,
uh,
when there's something called
aggravating circumstances,
so more than just
knowingly taking the drug,
taking the drug and lying,
trying to cover it up,
taking multiple drugs,
one trying to hide the other.
Yeah,
you could,
you could get double,
um,
uh,
the sanction amount.
So,
um,
you know,
on a second time,
anabolic steroid for years is
kind of the starting point.
You can go lower for mitigating factors.
You can go higher for aggravating
factors up to eight years.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean it would have to require something,
you know,
really severe degree just to
get to get up that bad high.
Has anybody ever gotten that hit?
Not In the UFC program.
Now,
what is the biggest hit that
anyone's ever gotten in the Yoh side?
I think thus far it's two years.
And it was that,
um,
I think a few people,
uh,
Chad Mendez comes to mind.
Chad Mendez,
his was some sort of
psoriasis cream or something.
His was an insulin growth factor one.
So IGF one.
And did he say that it came
from a psoriasis Korean?
I think he may have said that.
Yeah.
That was never proven or no,
I mean there was nothing and you saw it
as reasoning or their announcement of
why it was two years about you know,
any type of mitigating factor coming from,
cause I know he your sunrises
and someone had said or had red,
I didn't really investigate
very deeply into this,
but I remember reading that he had put
some sort of cream on and then that creem
was responsible for him testing positive.
Was that?
Yeah.
I don't know that's the case.
I do recall him saying that.
But you know,
hey an athlete can say anything
they wanted about why it happened.
If there was something mitigating,
they are afforded that right
to share with Usada that,
look I didn't do this on purpose.
It wasn't on the label,
the cream.
Usually in those instances where the
evidence does show that you will see,
you know,
a mitigating factor come into play
and a reduction in a sanction.
There wasn't any,
in that case it was the two years and
there have been some guys that have gotten
pretty low sentences.
Like Tim means is a good example,
right?
Tim Means did take something that was
tainted and you guys or you sought a,
got some of those samples from independent
stores found out those were also
tainted.
Yeah,
Tim means took a supplement.
It was a Kreatin.
Um,
and you know,
after he tested positive,
and again,
this is where Donna and I
come into play quite a bit,
you know,
when athletes test positive,
we reach out to them right away saying,
look,
we're here to help you here.
If there's help to be had,
uh,
will believe you tell you,
give us a reason not to.
Um,
I did that with Tim.
Tim said I'd never
heard of this substance.
Jeff,
I,
you got to believe me.
I didn't take it.
Said,
all right,
well let's start doing retracing steps.
What have you been taken?
Um,
he sent me,
you know,
maybe a half dozen supplements,
did some research on them,
worked,
uh,
reached out to kind of
contacts I still have in the,
in the industry from my law
enforcement days and said,
hey,
any of these kind of raise suspicions.
And there was one that did buy a company
that made some other kind of sketchy
products.
Um,
we narrowed in on that one pretty
quickly Senate to Usada too.
A lot of laboratory tested it.
Sure enough it had the substance in it.
Um,
then what happens is you saw it a will
independently procure some themselves.
So outside of the kind of touch of the
athlete to make sure the athletes not
contaminating with it for Brighton excuse,
they were able to get some
that was sealed and not opened.
And sure enough it,
it had that substance in it and it had
the same amount of the substance in it
that kind of matched up with
how much was in Tim system.
And when he said he had taken it last.
So there's a lot of detective
work that comes into it and I get,
I get this question a
lot from fighters saying,
hey,
the supplement excuse is
a bullshit excuse that,
you know,
there's athletes use and stuff and they
have supplements in their closet that
they know are tainted and then boom,
if they test positive,
they just have that built in excuse.
And what I tell them is it,
it's,
it goes deeper than that.
There's literally detect scientific
detective work that's going on from the
Usada side,
making sure everything matches,
making sure they independently
procure the product,
making sure what turns up in the Athlete's
system based on when they say they
were taking it matches exactly the
level that's in the product based on,
you know,
metabolism timings.
So it's much more than that.
And I,
I do have a lot of
confidence when you saw it,
it says,
Hey,
it does match that this is,
you know,
came from an unknowingly or unintentional
ingestion that it really is that now
in a case like Tim means,
why is he suspended,
is if someone does give him a tainted
supplement and he takes it in good faith
thinking that it's just creating,
right?
So,
so there are strict liability
in the program and you know,
they look at all the factors.
So,
you know,
creatine is a relatively low risk product.
However,
the Kreatin Tim took was not
third party certified and that,
you know,
get a lot of questions about,
man,
the supplement industry is dangerous.
And you know,
this sucks for,
for athletes.
There's nothing they can do.
There is something that you can do
and it's actually pretty simple to do.
Um,
we were talking earlier about,
about on it,
um,
a company you're,
you're involved with and,
and you guys third party
certify a lot of your product.
And what that means is you outsource
random testing of the product and sampling
of the product,
um,
from these independent companies to
make sure they contain no prohibited
substances.
And you know what don and
I educate our athletes too,
is you can go to these third
party certification companies.
I think you guys use Catlins group
banned substance control group.
There's that group.
Um,
there's informed choice.
there's NSF for sport and you can go to
their websites and they have lists of
all certified products and
there's hundreds of them.
So there's,
there's no excuse that you can't find as,
you know,
UFC athlete products that are tested
in an independently certified as banned
substance free.
And if it were the case,
and it's not saying that it couldn't
happen because those companies aren't
testing every single bottle of product.
But if you're an athlete,
you take a third party certified product,
you record it,
you log it,
and it turns out to be from that product.
I think then you're reaching a level
where the mitigating factors maybe do get
you down to no sanction,
you know,
a public warning or something.
Hey,
you know,
maybe you shouldn't use
supplements at all type of thing.
Right?
So his error was just taking something
that was not third party section and just
not doing his homework.
When a company there's a
responsibility for something like that,
six months,
it seems like a lot.
But in reality most it's a really,
he's really only got about three months
off because most fighters after a fight
are going to take a few months off anyway.
I mean it seems harsh but there is,
there is an obligation that fighters
need to do their homework and you need to
have a bit of a deterrent
there to make sure they do it.
And,
and that's that deterrent.
Now,
one of the things that I thought was
really cool about the EOC performance
institute,
which is just,
that's a,
there's so much cool about that place,
but one of the things that was really
cool is that you guys have a station where
an athlete can go in and
check any sort of substance,
any cold medication,
they're taking anything
type in the name of it.
And it'll tell you on
this like giant tablet,
whether or not what you're taking is band.
Yeah,
it's,
so it's,
it's a kiosk.
So as you sought a kiosk and we have
like a little iPad in there and it's
between the locker rooms
and the recovery room.
So it's United got your hot
cool and your pole cold pool,
um,
and your sauna and your
cryo and all that stuff.
So it's a constant reminder
as our athletes are in that
flow between that area.
Cause they all walked through there every
day that you saw it as a part of this
sport,
that we're a clean sport,
that you have an obligation
to check on medications,
supplements and you have an
obligation to file your whereabouts.
They can also file
whereabouts at that kiosk.
And we get athletes all the time
walking down that corridor or saying,
Oh shit,
I forgot to tell you sod.
I flew out to Las Vegas at the Pi.
Boom.
They can get on in a minute or
two and update where they're at.
So I have an APP,
they do.
So,
um,
so they can update by APP.
So it's on your phone as well.
So every quarter,
athletes are required to get
on a through a web browser,
what's called the quarterly
you saw to whereabouts filing.
They usually have to watch
an instructional video
most of the time reminders
about smart supplement choices,
um,
things like that.
And then they tell you saw to where
they're going to be for the next three
months.
And most of the time,
hey,
I mean I do Donna and I do the whereabouts
filing as well and we both say,
Hey,
who knows where I'm going to be next week,
let alone two or three months from now.
But you make your best guess at it.
And then all that information you put,
uh,
through the web browser is
downloaded to your mobile phone app.
So to,
as your plans change over
the next couple of weeks,
couple of months,
you can do 45 second to one minute
updates through your mobile app.
Um,
so the convenience is there.
There's really no excuse and
not letting you saw to know,
um,
where you're at.
There are repercussions if you
don't let them know where you're at.
Um,
because you want to avoid somebody,
you know,
ducking and dodging a test.
But no cowboy had a situation where he
was actually in Vegas at the fights and
they were mad at him cause he didn't
say that he was going to be in Vegas.
He's like,
I'm at the fucking fights,
I'm right here.
I'm on TV.
Don and I do everything we can to try
to let you saw to know that when we know
that a fighter has a UFC obligation,
so whether they're our
guests fight or on the road,
whether they're,
you know,
add a competition,
we're always passing that
information along to you saw that.
But we also tell them that ultimately
it's your responsibility as an athlete
will try to,
but you know,
we can't guarantee it ultimately was
going to fall on you if you don't update.
Now the good thing about this,
as you're afforded a couple of
mistakes under the whereabouts program,
so it's not until three whereabouts,
failures in any rolling 12 month
period that there can be sanctions.
Because honestly,
I mean,
things happen in your life.
Everybody's human.
Sometimes you forget.
I'll give you the perfect example.
So again,
getting back to Donna,
the most,
um,
attention to detail person that I've
ever worked with him at working career,
she comes over joints,
kind of our program here.
We get her signed up for whereabouts.
She was like,
this is great.
Like I can talk knowledgeably
about how to do this.
We went out to Anaheim for UFC,
I forget what number that was.
Um,
we take a trip down from
Anaheim to San Diego.
We went down to this clinic that we
were checking out for brain therapy.
She forgot to update that
she was going to San Diego.
She was more than two hours outside
of where she was supposed to be,
where you sought a new
shoe was going to be,
she would've gotten a
whereabouts failure again.
One of the mills responsible people that
I've ever been around goes to show that
it's challenging and in,
so she has to notify
where she's going to be.
We do it voluntarily just so we can
talk knowledgeably to our athletes.
So when they say,
oh,
this is too hard,
or you know,
we say,
well we do,
we do it right?
Yeah.
Here's,
here's a little trick that
I had to remind myself,
you know,
each day where I said I'm going
to be at things like that.
Now when you have a fighter like a Holly
Holm I think said she was tested nine
times in preparation for
this fight against Cyborg.
When,
when that happens,
is there a,
I know you can't say when the test is
going to happen because it won't be
random,
but is there any consideration about
the sleep cycle of the fighters?
Yeah,
I mean that's,
you know,
you saw it.
It never lets me know
when a test is coming.
I have zero input in terms of who's
being tested and that is the reality.
A lot of times they show up
five 36 in the morning show up,
really suck if fighters,
there is no doubt about it.
The bird and this,
the urine,
this is it.
Just a urine test can be blood as well.
I mean,
imagine you're dead asleep.
Six in the morning,
someone's knocking at your front door.
That's scary shit to begin with,
right?
You go downstairs,
you know,
you're trying to get ready for a fight,
prepare yourself,
sleep wise mentally,
and you've got to have a needle stuck in.
You had to get to draw blood,
wait until you got to take a pee.
Could be,
you know,
some fighters wait hours.
Um,
you know,
I don't think enough attention is
being paid to the burden that's on the
athletes and the credit.
They should be getting a Holly Holm.
I think I saw,
it's just a statistic that she's the most
tested athlete since the inception of
the program.
I think she's around 32 or 33
samples that she's provided.
I mean,
that's crazy.
Um,
but that I think she should not
enough credit is given to her.
Nobody,
they test her so many
times because she know,
I haven't heard any
suspicions of her being no,
neither have I.
And you know,
I think as you look at
the testing statistics,
and that's another cool
thing about program.
I don't know if you know that,
but all these tests,
numbers are publicly available.
So the transparency and this
program is unprecedented,
unparalleled as it comes
to professional sports.
There's no other professional sport on
the planet where you or I as a fan of the
UFC could say,
let me see how many times
Holly's been tested,
how many times Cyborg's been tested.
That's unparalleled.
Um,
but if you look at those
numbers and allocation,
we look at them.
I think those athletes with staying power,
those athletes that are at the tops of
their division have more tests directed
to them versus,
you know,
athletes at the bottom that
are jumping in and out.
They want to make,
I think you sought a good use of their
resources to make sure that they're
directing most of those tests.
Those athletes are going
to be around for awhile.
And I mean,
we saw what a bad ass Holly is on,
on Saturday night.
That woman's incredible.
And uh,
you know,
I think Sida probably realizes that too.
And she's going to be around
for a while and wants to set,
you know,
an example,
and I tell athletes a lot,
I say,
hey,
we're,
this is a badge of honor.
You know,
I know it's a burden,
but man that makes you even more
special of an athlete that you,
you know,
take that burden on and embrace it and,
and show the world that you're,
you know,
not only a bad ass athlete
but you're doing this clean.
And one of the things that I thought
was really fascinating about the UFC
performance institute
is that machine will,
you lie down and it scans your entire
body and it shows where your muscle
imbalances are and like what,
what are,
what are all the different
details I think focuses on.
Yeah.
I mean we talked about
this when he toured it,
but you've got to get,
you've got to get some of the personnel
from the Pii in there that can really
talk knowledgeably and have,
you know,
that education,
I'm going to bring those guys in.
They're going to come on.
Not only is that,
as you saw at that facility world class,
but they staffed it with the
perfect worldclass personnel.
So that machines called
a Dexa scan and you know,
I can't give it the justice
that the personnel can there,
but it yet measures body composition.
So it will measure,
you know,
fat,
um,
hydration levels,
bone density,
and as it is it,
how's it doing that some
type of low level x-ray.
Again,
you got to get those guys in
there to describe it specifically.
But you know,
I'm sure as a topic we'll cover today the
whole weight issue being in the proper
weight class and weight
cutting the both the,
the equipment and now the personnel in
place of the performance institute that
there's no excuse for an
athlete to not a fine their way,
right way class and B,
you know,
safely,
efficiently,
you know,
meet that weight goal.
Um,
when they're fighting,
everything is in place now there for that.
Now when a fighter comes to you guys and,
and lies down in that machine and,
uh,
you read their hydration levels and
say they're slightly dehydrated and yet
there's still 10 pounds
above the weight class,
how do you handle that?
So we have a director of sports nutrition
guy by name of Clint Wattenberg and
uh,
Clint was a division one
all American at Cornell,
Ivy League educated,
smart as hell.
Uh,
went on to wrestle with team USA.
It's actually wrestled with a lot of our
fighters have had several conversations
about with guys that,
that wrestled him before
Clinton came here.
So he's got,
you know,
a ton of pure respect for that.
I'm Super Smart Guy,
but yet he works,
you know,
he'd be the guy to ask.
He's,
you know,
Ivy League educated,
um,
in sports nutrition and
in a situation like that,
that he's,
you know,
given advice to the fighters about how
the importance of hydration and trying to
change that around so that
they can meet those goals.
Yeah,
there's the machine right there.
Um,
what is it called?
Dual energy x-ray absorbed
appsource beyond tree.
How do you say that?
We call it Dexa scan,
sore geometry.
That sounds like something that
like someone would say in a cartoon,
like a fake word.
It measures body composition
including lean mass,
muscle tissue,
fat mass and bone density.
Measuring and tracking all three of
these components is important for weight
class sport athletes and helps
guide nutrition recommendations.
Fascinating stuff.
So,
um,
it just sort of scans over.
Yeah.
How long has that test take?
A,
you don't,
I've never gone through it
or actually never seen it.
I've got to get over
there and check it out.
I Dunno.
It was interesting with
Forrest was t doing,
Forrest Griffin was telling me that uh,
when he had it done,
he found out that one of his legs has
two pounds more muscle than the other leg
because he had had some knee
injuries and you really had no idea.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
I mean,
so,
so forest is a big part of that.
Performance Institute was a big part of,
you know,
touring other facilities around the world.
I think him and James Campbell,
who's our VP of operations at the Pii,
went to 61 or 62 facilities throughout
the world and took would they believe
were the best parts of these facilities
and put them all to one and forces role
there.
Um,
is,
you know,
kind of similar to my role in the
anti-doping program and advocate for our
athletes.
He's there to make sure as
a former fighter knowing
what works and what doesn't
work.
Um,
we're looking at a video of this thing
right now and it looks like star trek is
it,
what does it saying anything Jamie,
very end of pans over and shows
what shows up on the screen.
There's a coming in like bunches
of different data points.
This is amazing.
Yes.
I mean I talked to you I thought maybe
last week and get you out there earlier,
but you got to come.
I'm going to next time.
Next time in March should come
day or excuse me a day early.
Just do,
they'll put you through the whole thing.
We get you get your Dexa scan done,
your body composition.
You then have a meeting with Clint,
talk about nutrition and goals.
Maybe go see the physical therapist,
talk about any issues you
have and therapy you need.
Go work out with our strength
and conditioning coach
both Sandovall it puts you
through the,
the ringers and the equipment there and
then do a little recovery after that
that really gave you the full experience.
Yeah,
that place is amazing how you
guys get it set up and it's,
it's really,
uh,
a massive resource for fighters that if,
because there's a lot of
great Jim's out there,
but I don't think I've ever seen one
that's that well equipped that you guys
have everything.
You have a complete strength
and conditioning system,
uh,
area.
And then you have a complete area for,
with heavy bags,
a cage boxing ring,
and then you have a
complete recovery area.
You have cryo machines,
you have that,
what does that light machine?
Yeah,
it's like low level laser light therapy
that looks like a giant tanning bed that
you get in.
And I've seen that thing before.
And what does that supposed to do?
It's supposed to somehow
or another stimulate that
work on your recovery and in
at the cellular level.
Again,
you need to get these,
these Pi personnel in here to,
to explain it in detail,
you guys even have sleep pods,
which I thought it was
the craziest thing ever.
It was so like if a fighter
just has like an hour to chill,
they can just get in there
and recover and relax.
Yeah.
I mean the idea is you come
to the performance institute.
Yeah.
They're there and don't get dope
and I hear this all the time.
They,
they see the,
the,
the equipment,
the personnel that's available to them.
They see when it's time to unwind that
they have a room like this to relax in.
They see you.
They have free use of the
cafeteria and custom cook meals.
They don't want to leave the place.
They're there all day long.
Frances and Ghana,
yeah.
Lives has lived there the last six months.
There's a running joke in the office at
Francis has constantly walking around
the office in between workouts.
It's like,
Francis,
we got to get you an office
here or something like that.
What are you doing?
Yeah,
that's the guy you saw.
I mean the dude move to la,
he saw the place and he moved
up and moved everything he had.
I don't think he knew anybody in
Las Vegas or not any friends there.
Cause he's,
he's just walking around the office all
day long when he's not at the Pi from
France,
from France,
from another country.
He said exactly.
But you know the perfect example of seeing
what that place could do for him and
that's available to every
single fight or on the roster.
Yeah.
I mean there's nothing like it.
And my prediction is that the UFC is going
to be the hub where most people live.
The only thing that's wrong
there is the altitude.
That's the only thing that's wrong.
And I know you guys have a hypoxic room
where you can stimulate or simulate a
high altitude.
Yeah,
I think 22,000 feet,
but isn't the way you're
supposed to do it?
You're supposed to work at sea level,
but sleep at high altitude.
Isn't that how it's supposed to be?
I think that's what it is.
You know what Does Bay,
so 2,500 3000 feet,
so it even isn't really,
that's interesting.
I didn't even know it was that high.
I think it is.
Yep.
I thought it was a little low.
I thought it was like c
level cause it's like desert.
No,
no,
no.
It's got a little bit out.
I know Nevada has some
good mountain areas though.
Just outside were guys can
run and do things like that.
Yeah.
Does,
does the performance institute take people
on any tracks or anything like that?
I don't think we've
gotten to that level yet.
I got to be a good thing to do.
Right.
Could make to red rocks for runs.
There you go.
It's a good idea.
I mean I just think that if really high
level coaches start moving there and
obviously we just lost one
of the best Robert Follis,
which is a huge,
huge loss.
And what a great guy and say,
I mean universally nicest guy
ever and it was a great deal.
Universally loved,
very few people that are fight
coaches that are universally
loved.
And Robert Really was.
But um,
you know,
Vegas has some good coaches,
but I anticipate more and more gyms
moving and relocating there and bring
fighters there because I just think high
level fighters going to see that place
and go,
how can I recreate this anywhere
without fucking millions and millions of
dollars?
I think so.
I mean,
we love to see that happen.
It's,
you know,
a good low cost,
relatively low cost of living area.
Um,
so it's a place that's affordable and uh,
yeah,
I think he spent a little bit of time
with the Pii and see what you can do,
what it can do for you as a UFC athlete.
And just when I was,
oh,
go ahead.
I think the other cool thing,
and I know Dunkin French,
he's doctor Dunkin France.
She's our VP of performance,
um,
there and a,
which he explained it a little bit to
you about is that not only are we looking
to influence the UFC athlete but also
influenced positively and I may the whole
the entire sport and what you're seeing
is UFC athletes can come in there and
use it,
but they can also bring along
with them training partners,
coaches,
and you know,
we're only seven or
eight months into this,
but what we've already seen as,
you know,
training ideas,
proper nutrition,
going back out to these gyms,
not only across the u
s but across the world.
So we definitely hope to be a positive
influence throughout all of them and May
and,
and really,
really grow the sport.
Yeah,
I saw that with Bobby Green,
Bobby Green who was there,
I brought a couple of his training
partners and just on a random day,
Wilson Hayes was there,
Angela Hill was there.
There's quite a few cycles thing ever.
I love,
I'll go over there when I'm in the office
multiple times a day just to see who's
in there that day and have,
you know,
that five,
10 minute conversation with a Wilson Hayes
that he knows me going forward in the
future and that Jeff's a cool guy and
when that medication or supplement
question comes up,
he's talked to me before,
he knows who I am is not afraid to pick
up the phone and asked me that question
versus hey,
this golden snitch character,
I don't know,
I don't know who this guy is not
going to call him or trust him.
It's a big part of what I do is
try to develop those pet trusts.
So thanks to shop or send me back about
two and a half years were developed in
that trust and a nickname
that doesn't even make sense.
It literally doesn't make sense.
But it's funny.
Um,
is there any other plans to expand
or do more things with the institute?
There is.
So we didn't show you this,
but there are other areas
upstairs for that very reason.
They thought about hey technology and a
couple of years or maybe new machines or
devices that come onto
line that we may want.
So there is additional
room for expansion there.
I talked to you guys and I
talked to Duncan about a tank,
about you guys getting tanks in there.
Uh,
s sensory deprivation tanks.
I think that would be massive.
I know a lot of football teams are using
them now and it's starting to spread,
um,
excellent source of magnesium because
you're absorbing it through the skin.
But just for relaxation recuperation.
I would be fascinated to
see if you guys had those.
Like what kind of results you'd yeah,
I mean it sounded to me,
and I was there when
you're talking about it,
that Dunkin was open to it and it
was talking about some research,
I think you said Ohio State University
is conducting some research on the
benefits of that.
So I know there's tanks in Vegas now.
I know there's a place in Vegas,
so I'm sure whoever runs that tank
thing going to reach out to me.
So I want to get you in touch with them.
And how just have you try it.
Just see if,
you know,
just,
just to get a beat on his,
it's a freaky experience and
it's really good for your body.
Just everything like in your back.
We'll just sort of just loosen up
because you're essentially zero gravity.
You're floating.
It's just,
everything's sort of pops and
loosens up and it's amazing.
It's cool.
I want to try it.
I saw yours a little bit ago.
It's little,
little intimidating or scary
and looking weird person.
My wife made me move
it out of the basement.
I had one in the basement.
She's like,
people come over,
they think you're afraid.
I think I'm a freak.
But um,
the idea behind it I think
is pretty sound and I think,
um,
there's a lot of benefits for it,
uh,
for fighters as far as
concentrating on technique as well.
I think it's an amazing place to focus
on strategy and game plans and movement
and things along those lines.
We can visualize one of the most
amazing things with the sport and I,
you know,
coming over to the UFC,
I call myself a fringe fan.
I'm Alec follow it a little bit,
but I'm,
I'm hook,
line and sinker into the sport now.
And the most remarkable thing I find
about the sport is the mental game.
It is the most incredible mental game of
any athlete in any sport in the world.
When you're walking out into an octagon
and facing one of the baddest mixed
martial artists and the planet.
And you know,
I know you've seen a ton
of fights over your career,
but I think one thing that,
that I've seen the two and a
half years and you may not,
is that progression through fight week.
So when I go out to these
events or events or in Vegas,
some there checking day Monday or
Tuesday at five week and typically we're,
we're on the road on there every day in
the same hotel and watching these guys
and girls eat breakfast.
I'm watching them at the gym prepare,
try to make weight on Friday.
I'm watching them Saturday morning with
the prospect of the fight ahead of them.
What an incredible mental journey it is
to know that you're about to get into,
you know,
a cage with one of the baddest
fighters on the planet.
Then even if you win,
probably come out,
you know,
with a little bit of damage,
I mean everything to,
to fight night,
fight night.
These,
these athletes are in a locker room,
typically with three
or four other athletes.
And especially if you're one of the last
athletes on that card and one by one
your locker mates are walking out
and then coming back in and you see,
you know,
damage on even the ones that win.
And unlike other sports where you get
out on the field and you warm up and you
get a little sense of what
the atmosphere is like,
these athletes are walking out,
you know,
into the lion's den,
seeing it for the first time and
the sensory overwhelming sensory,
uh,
things that are going on when doing that
and to be able to control your emotions
and,
you know,
compete against somebody is just
absolutely the most incredible thing that,
that I've ever seen.
I'm so amazed at,
and you know,
very few of these fighters and
I talked to a lot of them had,
doesn't get to them in some way or form.
Um,
that is uh,
you know,
talk to forest often about that enforce.
It's like it says he equates it to if
you'd never jumped out of an airplane the
whole time you're on the way up saying,
what the hell am I doing?
This is crazy.
And then,
you know,
when the bell rings
and you start fighting,
then it kind of calms
down your back in your,
your kind of zone.
But just what an incredible
mental game this is.
And I just have so much respect for our
athletes because of what they have to go
through and they're able to do it
time and time again and control those
emotions.
You bring up an important point and um,
mental training is something that a lot
of athletes have really concentrated on
more over the last few years than
I think ever that I could recall.
And a lot of them bringing hypnotists
and a lot of bringing in sports
psychologists.
Is there ever been any talk of bringing
that to the performance institute?
Yeah.
You know,
I've talked,
I talked briefly with
Dunkin about it who has it,
you know,
a ton of resources in the
athletic performance field.
And um,
so we've talked briefly about that.
But um,
nobody on the staff,
you know,
currently it's,
it's,
it's kind of a give and take.
Look,
we want to provide all these
resources to our athletes,
but we also want them to
retain their independence.
I mean,
you don't,
if you notice in the
performance institute,
there is no MMA coaches there.
There was no striking wrestling coaches,
Jujitsu coaches,
none of that.
That's for the athlete to bring in
because there needs to be some level of
independence.
You don't want to train the entire roster,
you know,
the same way itself.
Exactly.
It's exactly,
it sounds like it was.
I saw early on in my
tenure here with the UFC,
I saw one of the most
incredible things that,
that I've ever seen.
I've only seen it once,
but I saw a fighter show up,
fight night outside the locker
room and basically said,
I don't want to go in.
I don't want to do this at the arena.
Really?
And I mean,
I was just blown away.
And uh,
actually Sean Shelby went up
and thought it was awesome.
Had a great conversation with the fighter.
Said,
look,
you're not feeling anything that everybody
doesn't feel every single fight or on
the roster fields,
which you're feeling right now.
You're just letting it get the best you.
You know,
you're a Badass fighter.
you've kicked ass before,
you've gotten beat before.
Uh,
you know,
what's the worst going to happen?
You're going to,
you're going to get beat.
You're going to live through this thing.
You're just letting it surface.
Everybody feels what you're feeling.
And for a second,
you know,
the fighter came back a
little bit and then boom,
left the arena.
Whoa.
Crazy.
But I think that must enter into
the head or the prospect of that,
of every single person,
every single fighter
that comes here being,
and I'm sure there's just a little
bit of that and the back of the head.
It's just an incredible journey
to see them mentally overcome.
Um,
that amount of stress.
The pre fight is incredible.
Why it's so interesting to see a guy
like Conor who silver laxed in there.
It's kind of weird,
you know,
like when he does that rubber
arms strut loose walking
around the cage,
he's Kinda like letting you know how
he is dealing with this better than you
are.
You know,
the one fighter that,
uh,
cause I paid really close attention
after having seen that early pay really
close attention just to see
that fight or on the walkout,
like to sit in a pretty close to the cage
and just look at that fighter's eyes.
And I,
I tend to see a little bit
of nervousness and fear and,
and everyone,
I think it's probably healthy.
One person that sticks out that I looked
at and I saw nothing in this dude's
face.
I saw like a little smirk,
like he was so happy to be in there and
it's the first time I've seen this guy
fight and that's just engaging.
When he fought Michael Johnson,
I remember look,
and he walked in first and I was sitting
on one side and he's on the other side
of the cage and looking in his eyes
and I had never seen him fight before.
And I'm like,
who is this guy?
He looks like he's happy to
be in there like this is,
you know,
some parties at.
And that fight was incredible.
Well,
he's crazy,
wasn't it?
He's legitimately crazy.
He said that getting knocked
out by Eddie Alvarez,
the greatest thing that ever
happened to him in his life,
he's a different breed.
Yeah,
well he's got a mindset
and that mindset is,
um,
coming to go to war.
And he said it when he got signed,
he said,
uh,
over the next couple of years,
I'm going to get knocked out.
Someone's going to knock me out.
He goes,
but I'm going to knock a lot of people
out and I'm going to break people,
you know?
And the only way to
stop me to shut me off.
And he goes,
I'm human.
I can be shut off.
I want to watch that guy fight every time.
Every time.
Yeah.
I mean that's an incredible mindset.
And I don't know if you can teach that.
I think a lot of people say you
can't teach mental strength.
And I don't,
I think that's horseshit.
I think you could teach everything.
I think the mind can be,
can be trained.
I mean this is what they do in bootcamp,
right?
I mean,
and it works to varying
degrees of success.
I think the mind can be trained.
It's just a matter of
what's your baseline?
Where are you coming in at?
Are you a total scaredy cat
or are you a pretty stoic,
rugged dude to begin with?
And what can they do?
And maybe,
maybe you're too stuck.
Maybe you're,
you're too nonemotional and
you're to non vulnerable and you,
you're delusional and your perceptions.
It's amazing seeing the different ways
that different athletes deal with it.
So Saturday night,
I give you a perfect example.
So fight night,
um,
you know,
you saw it as the one doing the testing.
A lot of times fight night.
There's not a lot going on in my world
on there to put out fires in case
something does go on.
I like to watch the fights close.
Um,
just to see those things
we're talking about here.
So,
but occasionally I'll,
I'll pop in backstage just to
make sure everything's going good.
So I walked back there before the Holly
Cyborg fight and so Holly was out in the
Hallway,
um,
getting ready to do that long walk for
the championship bout and she was there
for probably about 10 minutes.
Camera's getting ready
and she was doing that.
Holly pacing back and forth and her
hands together firing herself up when she
did it for a good 10 minutes back there.
And then you see,
once she gets in the cage,
she was the first one in their
pacing back and forth for 10 minutes.
Right.
Hitting the hands together every between,
every single round she'd get
off that stool back and forth,
pacing,
hitting the hands together.
That's the way she fired herself up.
She Carlos bars,
we'll walk out.
She walks out with like
zero emotion on her face.
Like,
is this girl ready to go?
She gets in the cage,
walks over one side and just stands there
and doesn't bounce around at all that
you know,
hey,
you see both,
both of them,
you know,
can have success doing that way.
Dealing with,
you know,
it's amazing to see it.
There's a groove that they get into,
they get,
they get in the comfort zone.
They just like,
this is what I do.
Every time I've compete and
everybody's is different.
And you know,
some people don't like to bounce around.
But I remember when Holly did that
during the Ronda Rousey fight.
I remember how I was looking at her.
I'm like,
this girl's got some legs.
I was like,
I'd seen her fight before and I
knew that she was and some stamina.
I mean,
between the 10 minutes backstage before
she walked out the five minutes after
she was in the cage and Cyborg is walking
out the 10 or 15 seconds between every
round.
She probably,
you know,
ran a couple of miles.
Yeah.
The equivalent of a couple
extra rounds and she was,
yeah,
she was as fresh at the end of,
she wasn't beginning tremendous cardio.
And that girl,
well,
Jackson's camp,
you know that Michael,
uh,
excuse me,
the uh,
Greg Jackson and Mike Winkeljohn camp,
they,
they spend a lot of time
working on endurance training,
strength and conditioning and
they do a lot of hill running.
You know,
they have this famous mountain
that they run that they all do.
And just Holly's been known
for not just her cardio,
but like I said in the Rhonda fight,
her legs,
the way she can move.
Yeah.
I,
that's one of the things that I thought
was going to be a big problem with her.
With Rhonda.
It was like Ron has got to catch her,
like the way she's bouncing and moving.
I don't think Rhonda can move like that.
I'm like watching her bouncing move and
that crazy kickboxing style that she'd
had for all those years or ability
to do back flips and stuff.
She's really athletic.
She's a different
different level of athlete.
Yup.
Yeah.
But cyberark is just too big,
too big,
too skillful to tough show.
She showed a lot.
She showed a lot of skill in that fight.
I was,
you know,
her previous UFC fights,
she was just kind of
coming at people and mall.
I thought she was really
skillfulness five very,
very patient too.
You know.
I mean a lot of people want to
say that she's just a brute,
but she's not like she's,
she's,
she knows what her skills arm,
which is big power and excellent Moy Tai.
But she also administered that power.
The way she delivered
it was very skillful,
very,
very methodical,
very professional.
And that was a workman like really was.
It was initially I talked to somebody
in our camp and they wanted to see a
little bit more of that
brute power come right out.
And they thought she was
holding back a little bit.
Maybe a little too skillful,
but I thought it was great.
While they want her to stop,
you know,
a Holly,
but you running the risky,
getting head kicked.
Sure.
You know,
you gotta be real careful with Holly
Holly pull stuff out of our ass.
You know,
like he sat in the drain and
Germane to random he phi,
he saw it and obviously the Rhonda fight,
she needs very sneaky.
She knows how to,
especially that left high kick man.
She knows how to sneak down such a great,
that was a great fight.
Love watching that fight.
Yeah.
The women's MMA talent level
has risen and risen and it,
it is,
I mean,
I remember when it first came on the
scene and Rhonda was the champ and she was
just kind of roll in these girls who
really didn't belong in the ring with her.
It how it has and you know,
interesting.
Bringing back to the
performance institute,
you know,
talk with guys a lot over there that
what they're finding out is you need to
train a female athlete in a much different
manner than you train a male athlete.
Um,
you know,
you see a lot of times when
female athletes cut weight,
difficult difficulties,
they have cutting that way because of,
you know,
menstrual cycles potentially.
And you also see in a lot of cases,
a rebound effect where
a female will fight,
get down to weight,
fight,
and then bounce way back up
and just lose the ability,
the body's ability to regulate where
there'll be cutting down on calories
working out like crazy and
they're still putting on weight.
Um,
so I mean,
I think that's something that you'll see
the performance institute doing is try
to,
you know,
figure out and then knowledgeability
disseminate information about how to train
the female athlete that they may need
a little bit more time off and recovery
between fights than a male athlete will.
But one thing I say,
time and time again is every
time we have a female fight,
they come to fight.
And you often see cards that are,
you know,
kind of lagging a little bit
and you look down on the list,
okay,
there comes a female fight,
boom turns the car and ride
around because you know,
inevitably they,
they give ultimate
maximum effort in there.
That's at least what I see.
There's a lot of that.
Well,
there's the,
the t,
excuse me,
the talent level is rising.
They're very hungry and they're,
they're looking to be that next person.
They realize like,
look,
Ronda Rousey is gone.
No one has really filled her place.
I mean there's some very popular fighters,
you know,
like a rose Nama units obviously now
is going to be one of the most popular
fighters after the knock out of
you on e and j check cyborgs,
obviously very popular,
but there's plenty of room for
more and they realize that,
look,
this is the time to go for it.
And I just think that,
you know,
the women that get involved in
fighting in the first place,
it's not,
there's a lot of men that
get involved in fighting.
They're not going to fight after awhile.
But women that get involved in fighting,
they tend to be crazy,
like in,
in a good way.
You know,
like these are wild women,
you know,
like cats in Ghana type characters.
You know,
they're just wild.
And like when you watch them fight,
I mean,
you,
you're going to see some chaos.
I mean,
they're,
they're not going to be playing it safe.
They're going to be going for it.
Yeah.
I love that about him.
Now,
cat is an interesting example because
she was telling me the exact same thing
that you were saying
that with a lot of women,
their body responds very poorly to the
weight cut and then immediately wants to
gain weight afterwards.
Yep.
Do you think that that's a,
some sort of a,
uh,
like an evolutionary
feature because of their,
the fact that they carry babies and
Mckinney they need fat so thereby freaks
out?
I've definitely thought that.
Sure.
Or some sort of a response.
Like your body's like,
Hey,
I don't know what this crazy person is
doing but we've got to put some fat on.
Absolutely.
And that's,
you know,
that's something we're again going
back to the performance institute that
they're their,
their dive in deep into and
Clinton Wattenberg especially
on the nutrition side
that,
you know,
seeing those endocrine
profiles after a fight,
you know,
what can you do both and cutting
back and training and you know,
through your,
through your diet to help
control and regulate that.
And Kat was telling me about a
program that you guys were just,
you were just mentioning briefly in San
Diego where they're using some sort of
magnetic frequencies on fighters
that have had brain injuries.
Like what,
what is this?
Yeah,
what was something that the doctor Dunkin
French kind of brought into the mix
here?
Um,
so previous come into UFC,
he was director of sports performance at
University of Notre Dame in south bend,
Indiana.
And they were looking into,
um,
you know,
traumatic brain injury and
football and possible therapy.
Um,
and they came across a clinic in San
Diego that was using this therapy and FDA
approved device.
It's basically low level magnet therapy,
um,
in conjunction with that,
they do some EKG or reading of
the electrical waves in the brain.
And you know,
uh,
initially we're finding that this therapy
was bringing some of those readings
back together and,
uh,
I think very early,
um,
in,
in the process of figuring out
whether this can really work or not.
But you know,
certainly with the UFC wants to be as
ahead of the curve in terms of potential
therapies out there for,
um,
you know,
for treating the brain.
Um,
and so,
uh,
yeah,
cat's been going there for a while and um,
you know,
as I said,
she says she's experienced
some positive results.
Yeah.
She's,
she told me she got some
outstanding results.
And what's interesting is there's been
a ton of research and studies done on
transdermal stimulation,
all these different,
uh,
ways to increase the,
the brain's ability to learn.
And um,
there was a radio lab podcast on this,
I think it was called
something nine volts,
if you could find at nine
volts something or another.
But it basically detailed how they
use this for a sniper simulation.
And what they did is they took
this woman who was a reporter,
um,
they put her through this
sniper simulation games,
like a video game.
She scored poorly and then,
yeah,
nine volt Nirvana.
Thank you Jamie.
And so then they attach these electrodes
to various areas of her head and
stimulated her brain with a small charge.
And she went through the exact same
thing and she said it felt like the 20
minutes went by in two minutes and her,
her score was perfect.
And this is being echoed throughout like
many different people that have done
tests on these very,
and there's a lot of like home hacking
where people are literally going to radio
lab and making their own setups.
But I'm curious to
see if the UFC has looked
into some of these things.
Like some like maybe perhaps there's
a way you could stimulate the body's
ability to learn certain techniques or
like carve pathways by stimulating areas
of the brain.
Yeah,
man.
Another great reason for you to get
Duncan in here because he can talk real
knowledge to be about this therapy.
He told me when at the
University of Notre Dame,
you know,
they'd have,
they've had football players,
it would,
you know,
have migraine headaches for long periods
of time than under what this therapy in
a matter of weeks they were,
they went away.
Um,
when Donna and I visited the
facility down in San Diego,
they talked about,
uh,
employees of the facility,
bringing in their kids,
a kids that had some levels of autism
that after this therapy were more engaging
with people.
They also talked about kids that had
tests or finals coming up the day after
where they go in for this therapy the
night before and get their test scores
were improving as a result.
Um,
it was a lot of,
they deal with a lot of special forces
soldiers down in the San Diego area that
have had traumatic brain
injuries because of,
you know,
ids and a,
I've seen some success there.
So I mean,
I think some real exciting
potential there that again,
you know,
the UFC wants to be at the
forefront of and you know,
be the first to,
you know,
to suggest some of these things
for our athletes and you know,
potentially even looking,
getting some of these devices at the Pi,
um,
and be able to treat some
of our athletes there.
Yeah,
that would be amazing.
And I think that we're in an
interesting time now where,
because so much research is being put
on CTE and traumatic brain injuries that
were,
we're looking at potential
ways to mitigate those
problems and maybe even rehab
some of the issues that
fighters of having.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
one thing we didn't show
you and your tour is a,
we now make part of the
onboarding process at the Pi,
the c three logic testing,
which is this,
you know,
25,
30 minute neurocognitive tests that came
out of the Cleveland Clinic brain study
and it's an iPad based tests.
Um,
it's a mix of memory,
shape,
recognition,
balance.
You actually,
you know,
put the pad on your,
onto a belt,
you stand on this unstable surface and
close your eyes and it basically gives
you measurements or readings
after 25 or 30 minutes.
And then,
you know,
over time you can compare those readings.
If they're declining,
maybe it's time to take a
little bit of time off from,
from training and fighting.
Um,
if they're staying stable,
then you know,
maybe you know,
you're doing all right.
The California Athletic Commission
requires that for all fights.
So all fighters in any card in California,
the Wednesday or Thursday before the
fight goes through the c three logic
testing,
all of it's uploaded to a cloud.
So you don't,
after a period of a couple of years,
um,
a fighter can have access to
some real objective data on,
you know,
with the neuro cognitive capabilities are
looking like that would be a great way
to find out.
I mean maybe one of the only ways to
find out without fighter to declaw
disclosing
it,
whether or not a fighter has been
knocked out in camp because that,
that's a common occurrence that fighters
get knocked out in camp and hard
sparring and then a week,
two weeks later have to fight and
their ability to take a shot is gone.
Sure.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
you know,
often asked about that and comparing
it to other sports leagues.
And the one thing I will say,
you know,
with Nma now this is excluding
things are going on in the gym,
but in a fight that's regulated
by the Athletic Commission,
I think.
And then may have some of the most
conservative return to play policy.
I know it does have any sport we're in.
If you're an NFL quarterback and
you get knocked out on a Sunday,
yeah,
you're in a concussion protocol,
but they're trying to get you back plan
probably the next Sunday or the Sunday
thereafter,
which is crazy.
The big concussion and MMA as you know,
there's like a 45 60 mandatory 45 days,
no activities,
60 days before you fight.
I mean,
we've seen suspensions out to six months,
mandatory medical suspension.
So,
and some of them I think
are very warranted.
I mean there's some brutal brutal
knockouts where like Alistair Overeem and
Francis and [inaudible] like,
I don't want to see
Alistair fight next month.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
and here's a question
about a guy like Allister,
Allister,
we looked it up one day on a podcast has
been stopped or knocked out somewhere
in the neighborhood of 13 times in MMA
and then three times more in kickboxing.
What,
what's the number where you like,
that's enough.
Yeah,
I don't know the answer to that.
Um,
I know you talked with Allister
and Scott and his wits about him.
That's what's crazy.
Allister doesn't even
seem remotely punching.
I mean,
he is not only that,
he doesn't seem deterred,
like it's crazy.
Like he gets knocked out and he's like,
well,
we go back to the drawing board and uh,
we'll be better next time.
Like,
I think it's an unknown now.
But you also look at,
you know,
the UFC has been the largest contributor
to the Cleveland Clinic fight or brain
health study.
So we,
you know,
made I think multimillion
dollar commitment.
Uh,
we've upped it once.
Um,
so yeah,
we're looking to invest resources into
finding out what those answers are
definitely.
And be at the forefront of any
innovative therapies that are out there.
Innovative,
you know,
testing.
It's out there.
We want to be at the front.
Well,
the,
the issue with CTE is that you really
can't test for it until after a fighters
dead.
Correct.
But haven't they recently figured out a
way to test people while they're alive?
Yeah,
I'm,
I've read some of that.
I've also read that
scientists arguing that,
that,
you know,
that's fine and that's not right.
So I don't know where we're at on that.
Yeah.
Because boy,
it just seems like
I don't want to end.
It also affects people differently,
right.
Depending upon what genes they have,
some people are more predisposed to CTE.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's my understanding of it.
Again,
a lot of unknowns.
But um,
you know,
I think that the UFC has
shown a dedication to,
you know,
contributing to areas where we can
find out some of those answers.
Yeah.
Um,
like I know that you guys recently had
mark come to Vegas because Mark Han had
talked about suffering damage
from fights in the UFC.
Said,
you know what?
We can just hear him say that we're
going to pull them off this card.
And he was furious and they said,
look like we love you,
don't get it wrong,
but we want you,
we want you to be safe.
And you say that you're
slurring your words.
And then he changed it and said,
well,
it's after a few drinks
and then then went,
okay,
well come by and let's give you the full
gamut of tests as exact what happened.
And we're always going to act
out of an abundance of caution.
And in a scenario like that.
And so now he's back on the roster
and back with a fight scheduled.
He's fighting in Perth and in February.
So when a guy says something like that,
you just Kinda have to,
you have,
when a guy says,
I'm slurring my words,
I've been,
I've taken too much punishment.
Like,
okay,
we've got a red flag here.
You have to,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
that happened.
I looked back to on a few member
when Kane was gonna fight a,
at the end of last year asking,
you came out a week or
two previous saying,
man,
I'm in so much pain from this back issue.
I'm having to use medical marijuana
CBD leading up to this fight.
The only way I can train,
I'm going to have this surgery
directly after the fight.
Um,
it was actually a Nevada
commission that saw this and said,
wait a second,
if you're really in that much pain,
like we can't with good conscience,
I'm license you to fight.
And sure enough they didn't do that
and ended up having the surgery and uh,
hopefully as back pretty soon.
But it's been like a year now.
Yeah.
He's a guy that is almost too tough
for his body or maybe is to tougher his
body.
If you watch cane fight,
particularly early in his
career when he's in his prime,
you just couldn't believe the amount of
endurance that a 240 pound man can have.
The,
the just the pace that he would put on
guys and you'd see them just drowning in
that pace.
But the only way you get,
I mean you have to have some physical
gifts cardiovascularly and I think Kane
will admit that he has some,
uh,
some natural cardio,
but unbelievable work
ethic and mental toughness.
And that mental toughness also makes
you push through injuries and pushing
through injuries is how
injuries become chronic.
And that's how injuries become
unmanageable and require surgery.
I mean you would know I,
I'm,
I was an athlete and went
through my share of injuries,
but you know,
I played basketball and ran
track and in those sports,
you know,
depending on your injury you can control,
I think your exposure
and protect your body.
I mean,
how do you do that in fighting?
You can't,
you can't,
you can't prevent certain positions
that your lot you're going to be in.
And if you're not completely healthy,
you're going to be probably exposed
from the only thing you could drill.
I mean,
if you really injured and you have a
good opponent or a good training partner,
you can drill on certain things and say,
hey man,
you just can't touch my shoulder
but there's no way you can spar.
And there's no way you could really
prepare for a fight without really hard
training and hard training with,
with injuries is virtually impossible.
I mean,
we,
with some injuries,
you know what I mean of them,
you can work around.
This is ways to figure
a way around things.
And that's one of the things that I've
found was really interesting also about
the UFC performances too,
does there's a lot of different things
that you guys have devised or have,
you know,
you've guys are brought in and implemented
that other people have devised to
help people with injuries that
are trying to still train hard.
Like that gravity treadmill
thing that's in our,
in our altitude chamber.
So you strap that around
you and you're getting not,
you know,
I don't know what the ratio is too.
You know,
if you're true weight to what type of
stress you're putting on your body,
but it's much less and going out and
run it on a regular treadmill or on the
street now outside the
underwater treadmill,
which you saw.
So that was weird.
Angela Hill was on that and I was like,
what's that like?
She's like,
it's weird.
Yeah,
it's like,
it just seems like the floor is moving.
You've got to check,
keep up with it.
Basically it's a rising floor.
So you rise up to the top,
you step on it,
and then it drops down and it works
like a regular treadmill because you're,
but because you're under water,
you're putting less stress on
obviously your lower extremities.
And if you notice also there's cameras
underwater with a TV screen right in
front of,
of the,
uh,
the person using them.
The idea there is if you have an
ankle injury or a knee injury,
you could take a look at how your foot's
coming down and are you favor in it and
what's your,
your gate looking like?
So cool piece of equipment.
Connor was using that quite
a bit and in the run up to,
uh,
to Floyd,
he put a lot of stuff out there
on social media on that thing.
I think you liked it.
Yeah.
Well he's got a bum knee,
right?
He's got a niece that has had a,
he's had some issues with in the past.
There it is.
That's done.
There's a Dunkin French
off there to the right,
I think.
Just drops you down and
then you run in that thing.
Yup.
Yeah.
Oh Man,
I'm not 100% sold on that
to be honest with it.
That's why I should come out and get it.
Get on it.
Yeah.
I mean I'm sure it's difficult,
but I think that like actually carrying
your weight and running on hills is a
way to go probably now look,
if you're coming off an ACL surgery,
right,
and you know you're taking baby
steps to get back to running,
it's probably there.
Otherwise,
if you're healthy and you know,
training for a fight coming
up in a couple of weeks,
I don't know if that's necessarily,
that's he's good equipment for you.
He's a guy that I'm puzzled by.
Conor.
Obviously I'm a gigantic fan,
but man,
his cardio,
it seems like there's a thing there.
There's something there.
Whether it's the style that he fights,
the explosive sprinting
style that he fights,
it's unsustainable,
you know,
or whether or not there seems to be some
sort of an issue that that needs to be
addressed.
Some much more radical approach
to a strength and conditioning.
And I would love to see the guys that
performance institute try to tackle that
and try to figure out,
I mean,
I'm sure they've run vo
two Max is on them and,
but he gets it.
He did most of his camp there,
but you know,
he had his own team around him
that was kind of directing him.
Um,
but in his defense,
this was a very quick camp.
You're getting ready for a 12 round fight
with the greatest fighter of all time
in boxing.
Jesus Christ.
It's like six or seven weeks.
I think Floyd knew what he was doing.
I tell you one of the incredible things
about that and there wasn't a lot said
about it going back to kind
my world anti-doping world.
So Floyd does this for all his fights.
He basically hires you
sought to do testing.
Um,
it's not,
you know,
it's not the same as the UFC program
where you're subject to testing year round
in boxing.
Once the fight has made you saw to
then comes in and does collecting.
So it depends on how far
out the fight was made.
But Conor and Floyd sign that contract,
was it seven weeks out?
Maybe they were each tested
16 times and that seven weeks.
And I guarantee you they are the two
most tested athletes and that pure short
period of time ever in the
history of anti-doping.
So not only was it a
incredibly cool event,
but I think incredibly clean,
cool and clean for the fans and know that
you know how out of the way those two
guys went to ensure that that
fight was fair and clean.
That is amazing enough credit for that.
It's too bad.
There's not too performance institutes
or you could have one right next to each
other.
We're opponents could train at very,
you know,
like you could film things at
the performance institute in a,
at a level.
Um,
Forrest Griffin was showing me how the
octagon is set up with 360 degree cameras
and you could literally film
and then rotate angles up down.
You can,
you can move around and show,
oh,
when you're throwing this punch,
your back foot is coming off the ground.
When you're leaning to your left,
you're dropping your hand.
It's like the John Madden telestrator
do stop action and draw on that huge big
screen next to the octagon around
exactly what Floyd was shown.
Or excuse me,
when,
um,
uh,
forest was showing me how
you can move it around.
I was like,
this is insane.
Like this.
What a tool this is for
technique development.
It really,
and I think we're at the infancy of,
of these coaches coming in and figuring
out how they can use these things he had
sent that they can benefit their funders.
I mean that,
there it is right there.
Yeah.
This thing,
oh,
there's my tour.
Well,
did somebody put that up on
these fucking on already?
They put it up.
Um,
I didn't put this,
Oh yeah.
Put It on my Instagram stories,
but I didn't put it on Youtube.
Somebody put it on youtube here.
So what what force was showing me was how
they can pause it and slow mo and back
it up and then change angles and that
all the fighters sparring sessions or
filmed their film from an overhead,
their film from the sides.
And there's cameras
all around the octagon.
I mean it's just what a facility man.
Yeah.
I mean I really think
we talked about this.
This is bringing the sport
to a whole new level.
Yeah.
Well Frances is going to be your
first test tube sorta child.
Yeah.
You know you talked about,
wouldn't it be nice to have two
opponents working side by side?
The Pi has that capability.
I mean as you saw it,
it's set up specifically.
So you have certain things downstairs
and certain things upstairs so you'd have
to schedule it.
So Steve Bay says,
Hey man,
I want to come out and use this.
It is,
it is open to Steve Bay.
We could schedule it.
So Steve Bay's downstairs doing a strength
and conditioning and while Francis
was upstairs,
it's a lot of what forest does force,
you know,
it could be the intermediary to
make sure Francis goes out one door,
Steepbank comes in another
never run into themselves.
But that definitely has taken
them and they are there.
But yeah,
but what I would,
if I was tpa,
I would not want to be doing strength
conditioning and then in between sets,
just like have your ear
and you hear Coppola.
Francis is hitting the heavy
bag and scaring everybody.
You your style.
You tried that,
that punch machine.
Yeah,
he's got the world record punch on that.
There's a,
what it is is like a for folks,
it's a pad.
It's adjustable,
it moves up and down and you punch it.
And not only did he
break the world record,
he broke it by several thousand
pounds per square inch.
Yeah.
I think his reading,
and I don't know what the reading is,
was 129,000 something and yeah,
he's terrified.
It is.
You hit it a couple times,
man.
I thought you were hitting pretty hard.
Now,
what did you register?
Like a 35 or 40,000?
I got 46 is my hardest one to,
I hurt my hand.
He kind of put gloves on to do that too.
I would imagine that being wrapped up
and that's an argument that I've had many
times when it comes to MMA in general.
I like how you can angle it so
you can throw an uppercut as well.
Um,
that's an argument that I've had.
for MMA in general,
I think it's weird that we,
uh,
are allowed to elbow with no pad knee
with no pad kick with no pad on the Shin,
but the knuckles are protected.
And I think that it really probably
allows people to deliver more damage with
the knuckles padded.
I don't think padded knuckles helps
your opponent as much as it helps you.
And especially risk protection.
Like when I was trying to punch
that thing with just my bare hands,
um,
which is stupid,
especially when you haven't warmed up.
Right.
But you're,
you realize like your,
your wrist moves around,
he's slamming of that thing
and if you're hitting it hard,
your wrist moves around.
Well that's the case.
When you're punching a person to like,
you have to be much more precise with
where you're targeting and what you're
hitting.
You can't hit foreheads and elbows,
you'll break your hand like very easily.
And I wonder,
it's just,
it seems barbaric to people to,
to fight bare knuckle,
which to me is kind of
crazy cause you're kicking,
like you're,
you're shinning people in the
head like I don't understand.
Like we have this weird sort of childish
view of like what should and shouldn't
be.
Legal elbows are some of the hardest.
I mean,
you can just do that with an
owl and it doesn't hurt at all.
You know,
your knees,
your shins,
those guys that,
uh,
spar Muay Thai for a years and years,
their shins develop calcification all
over the top where they can kick baseball
bats.
Like there's trees.
Yeah,
it's,
there's a great one.
Have a bull cow,
uh,
kicking a banana tree just going cray.
And he's one of the greatest
tie fighters of all time,
but he's,
he's chopping at this banana tree
and cuts it in half and you're like,
Jesus,
like how is it okay that that guy can
kick someone in the face with that?
But you have to have pads here.
He was right here.
Like,
give me some volume on this.
Okay.
Waken a fucking tree.
I
is not doing that with his bare
knuckle will tell you that.
That's insane.
Fucking hit in the face with that.
But see the difference
like that's hard bone.
Yeah,
no padding.
Why do you have to have padding on your
knuckles but you don't have to have it
on your shins and your
knees and your elbows.
That seems to me to be a silly
way of approaching everything.
Yeah.
I mean maybe we could pat up everything,
but then people get mad.
Yeah.
Like we're posing for the sport.
I think you go the other way.
I think you don't pat up anything.
I think you pat up your
Dick and that's it.
That's what I think.
Pat Up your teeth pad up your Dick.
Let her rip.
I really think they
should fight bare knuckle.
I just don't think it
makes any sense whatsoever.
Especially considering
the fact that I poke.
So one of the major considerations,
right.
You're not going to mitigate
that with those gloves.
You're just,
you know,
unless they develop some sort of a new
designed where the gloves are much more
curled in.
Yeah.
Um,
there,
there's the,
the I pokes or it was
going to be an issue.
It would be the exact same
issue if you had bare knuckle.
Well,
yeah,
I mean now you can take away
with a new unified rules,
which,
uh,
ironically enough aren't unified.
Yeah.
I'm so we go from commission
to commission and you know,
flight or what have to inform them.
Fight week,
Hey,
what are the rules here that's so unfair
to these fighters that in our training
and developing that instinct
to some of these rules.
But anyway,
the new unified rules
which aren't unified,
um,
anybody who's extending the fingers
at the referee has to warn them first.
But they continue to do that.
A point can be taken away.
I think they should take a point.
Every time I got gets
poked in the eye and my,
my thought process is even
if it's unintentional,
the damage has been done.
And if,
uh,
if you could see it on the replay,
legitimate,
I poke and you see the guy and wincing,
like,
which we've seen many,
many times that guys compromised and I
think that it's only fair that a point be
taken away even if it was unintentional.
What's like,
you know,
kicking or needing a down fighter too,
that you know,
you have to show intent
to take a point away.
Right.
How is the referee going to get in the
head of a fighter to say whether or not
that was intentional?
Ride it,
it should almost be I
think that if it's done,
uh,
points taken away,
I agree.
Remove the intent from it because the
damage is already done at that point.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter whether
or not this intentional,
I mean,
we're not putting the
blame on the fighter.
It just,
it happened.
It's one of the unfortunate things,
but the fighter that got hit is the
one who suffers the consequences of it.
There's no way it should
be an even exchange like,
oh,
I'm sorry,
I accidentally need your eye socket it.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
no point taken.
And now you can't go on that.
That to me sounds,
I think there's room to,
to,
to alter the rules and I mean I,
I've,
I'm beating a dead horse with my bare
knuckle thing because I've been talking
about that for years because
I just think people have a
greatly exaggerated perception of the
effectiveness of punching people in the
face.
And I think that greatly exaggerated
perception is due to the fact that they
wrap their hands,
you wrap up your wrists and your,
your wrist and your hand becomes a
cast where it's not bending at all.
I mean you get deep in there with
athletic tape and Gauze and they cover the
knuckles and everything gets good at
it and you could just fucking blast
something with that.
But when you just have just your hands,
it feels very delicate.
I always tell people you should punch
the bag occasionally at least bare
knuckle,
just go and punch the bag and you realize
you can't really hit nearly as hard.
It's just,
I just think that we have like you
can't take the shit out of your ankles.
Right?
Right.
I mean we've stopped fighters from
walking into the octagon with fully tie,
taped up ankles,
you know,
pull some commissions,
allow light tape and then
a neoprene sleeve over it.
Others say no,
nothing.
Again,
the uniformity is again,
you know what to talk about uniform,
but he kind of bringing it
back to the anti-doping world.
This is a big point of contention
I have with athletic commissions.
Really,
really frustrated.
And that's the marijuana rules.
So you're talking my language is,
you have to see,
I thought.
So the UFC follows the water rules
world antidoping agency kind of sets the
world standard.
They have scientists that study these
drugs and determine a is something
performance enhancing B,
is it a health and safety issue?
And over the last couple
of years they rise.
They raised the marijuana threshold
used to be 15 nanograms per milliliter.
Now must succeed 150
nanograms per milliliter,
which everybody metabolizes differently.
But you know from scientists
that I've talked about,
the ingestion of marijuana or THC,
the psychoactive ingredient has to be
pretty damn close to that collection in
order to exceed 150
nanograms per milliliter,
which means you literally almost
have to be high the day pretty much.
So if an athlete just
takes a day or two off,
their most light suggests
longer than that,
just because you never know how different
people metabolize things differently
as you're cutting weight,
whether you're releasing
some from your fat cells.
I don't know,
I would suggest you know,
several weeks,
but the reality is it could
be a lot closer than that.
What we're running into
several athletic commissions,
Texas being one New York being another,
we had probably the most extreme one
last month in Michigan that have lower
thresholds.
Um,
Texas and New York have 35 or 50
Michigan where we just came from has a no
tolerance policy for marijuana.
So any measurable amount of THC
would cause a positive test.
And we lobbied them hard in
anticipation of our event.
They're saying,
do you realize what this means?
I mean,
a fighter could walk through
a cloud of secondhand smoke,
you know,
on the way to weigh in or a fight and
it's going to show up a measurable amount
and you're going to fight or could win
a championship on that and you're going
to take that championship
away and overturn the,
when we hadn't,
Texas a couple wins
overturned for a threshold,
which I think we're a little bit of,
I think 35,
it's your 35 or 50 was there,
but there were slightly over that.
Well under the,
you know,
established world standard and man,
I think these athletic commissions got
to take a serious look at bringing those
into uniformity.
You have,
you know,
in the u s should have certain states
now where it's legal medically and
recreationally,
but you know,
arguably federally,
um,
still illegal.
But you have some countries where it's
completely legal and you have doctors
prescribing this for,
you know,
pain control or stress
or anxiety and you know,
uh,
commission like Michigan,
one of those fighters from one of those
countries that is completely legally
doing it under the care of a doctor.
And in lieu of doing a synthetic drug,
like an opioid or a Xanax
or something like that,
common sense would tell you it's
much healthier and safer to do that.
Um,
you know,
you're setting up this barrier that,
could negatively affect a fighter's
career if they have any discernible amount
in their system.
And,
um,
you know,
not only from the unified rules but from,
from an anti-doping
marijuana's perspective to
these commissions have got to
come together and you know,
realize what the right
thing to do is and stop,
you know,
and a lot of instances stop governing
or policing just because you can.
Um,
we ran into that with the whole
Cortney Casey thing and in Texas,
I don't know if you familiar with that.
Yeah.
Just explain what happened.
So Courtney fought in Texas,
had a great win against Jessica Aguilar.
I think it was probably the
defining moment of her career.
She looked really,
really good.
Um,
a couple of weeks later,
I was actually at our event and Stockholm,
Sweden,
I mean,
it was vividly on a Friday night.
Um,
I got a call from her and I can't
even understand what she's saying.
She's just crying uncontrollably.
Saint Jeff,
you know,
what is going on?
I didn't even understand what it happens.
It slows down what happened.
So there's stuff on the Internet
about me testing positive.
I've,
I've never even thought about
using a prohibited substance.
I'm super careful about what I use.
So I said,
okay,
let me check into it.
And so I called a guy
on the Texas commission.
I said,
hey,
what's going on?
You know,
with this Cortney Casey thing?
And he tells me,
yeah,
she,
she tested positive.
We just announced it and I said,
for what she said,
or her tee ratio was elevated.
It was over a four to one.
And,
you know,
knowing with that measurement means,
um,
I said,
explain what it means.
Yeah.
So tee tee his testosterone,
he is Epi,
testosterone and every human being male
and female have on average a one to one
ratio naturally occurring in them.
And if you take anabolic steroids,
it can have a tendency
to raise that ratio,
um,
where the t becomes higher than the e.
Um,
however,
what anti-doping has found out and
evolved into the last few years that
especially mildly elevated ratios.
Sometime there are natural
reasons for that happening,
especially in females,
especially females on birth control,
which is illegal medication.
And so what you do now in anti-doping,
when you have an elevated tee ratio,
you go to a backup test.
That backhoe test is called an isotope
ratio mass spectrometry or earns test.
And that reads the carbon atom in the
testosterone in a sample to determine
whether or not it's plant based,
which would mean a synthetic
or it's naturally occurring
because testosterone is
synthesized through wild yams.
Correct?
Right.
So that's how they find out.
Let's plant based.
That's correct.
So Texas tells me,
hey,
her ratio was a little bit
higher than afforded one.
That means she's positive and they say,
they tell me,
we're just following your guys' rules.
And I tell the guy that's not our rules.
I go,
you just announced a
positive test for this girl.
And Hey,
you know,
maybe she did do something,
I don't know,
but you're supposed to run
the backup test for this.
And it was basically told me,
well it was a Friday.
He goes,
well,
our office is closed Monday,
we'll get back to you on Tuesday.
And really thereafter
it was radio silence.
So we were working with Courtney,
worked with Usada closely and
you saw a stepped in and said,
absolutely,
that is wrong.
We're going to go back and look at her
biological profile and we'll share that
with Texas.
We'll take a look at these tee readings
over the time of the samples that she
submitted.
Sure enough,
most of the samples were mildly elevated.
And sure enough,
you saw to do the right thing.
And they went and did that backup testing.
And every time they did
it she was negative.
So they reached out to Texas,
said,
hey,
we'll share this information with you.
And,
and,
and our historical records,
his girl does have a naturally occurring,
mildly elevated t ratio.
Uh,
then went through a several
week process of figuring out,
hey,
is there some of that sample remaining?
Because if there is Texas,
you have an obligation to go ahead
and do this backup testing on it.
Took them a number of weeks were poor.
Courtney was in limbo and I'm finally,
Dana put him on blast,
basically said Texas commission,
you know,
get your shit together.
We're not coming back there.
Um,
and we got ahold of that
remaining sample or be sampled,
had it tested at a lot of laboratory
and was negative on the IRM mass that
putting someone on blast works.
No,
it's,
it's an ego thing.
Like people are bitching at you,
you're going to succumb to that.
But yeah,
sometimes that's what it takes to
get someone to do the right thing.
It does.
So,
so this poor girl is living with the
fact that she's labeled as a cheater for
two to three months,
talked about she's still will be.
Yeah.
Well,
it's one of those things like once
someone says you're a steroid cheater,
we all,
the way she talked to,
I mean she lived,
she lives on Maui,
so small community.
She talked about going to the store and
people pointing at her talking bad about
her.
She talked about she,
she's a coach and a gym.
They're coaches,
kids about parents,
you know,
not one her to coach their kids
when this was inland labor,
how many of those people heard that she
was exonerated headlines on page one for
tat retraction on the back page.
Right.
And nobody pays attention to that shit.
And you know her performance
and she fought Detroit,
right?
Yes.
It was not a great performance for her.
And I can't help but wonder
if that had affected her,
you know,
over those last couple of months.
I think that was just stylistic.
You know,
I just think the way she matched
up with a Felice heric was just,
those two bulldogs are just
clashing heads with each other.
They just couldn't get anything done.
Could be.
I mean that,
but that's again going
back to the mental game,
a tremendous amount of stress to carry
with yourself through these last six or
so months.
Well I hope she gets past
that cause she's a lot of fun.
She's,
I like her a lot and
I got to tell you man,
it's one of the most satisfying things.
Again going back to the
golden snitch thing,
really my role here is as an advocate,
someone who looks out for
athletes and situations like that.
There's been other things that that
we do is look when we put this program
together,
the Sada program,
it was,
it's,
it's unprecedented.
There's no other professional sport
that has the comprehensiveness of the
program.
There's also no other professional sport.
It's quite put together like the UFC is
in terms of you have individual athletes
that you know are competing
against each other.
It's not a team sport worth
one person tests positive.
You have another person
you know to step on in.
So a lot of what I've done over those
first couple of years is take a look at,
you know,
hey,
we took,
we think it was a pretty good
shot at the rules to begin with.
But look and see how those
rules played themselves out.
As time went on and after
about a year and a half,
there were a couple instances where I saw,
hey,
this isn't quite fair to an athlete.
We need to change that.
We did.
So after a year and a half,
there was a couple rules that we change.
The first one,
there's kind of a funny
story behind this too,
was on if you remember
when Nate fought Conor,
I think the second time he goes to the
press conference after it takes out a
vape pen.
Do you remember that?
And someone asked him what he was
doing and he said he was with CBD.
And at the time though,
the rule was the in competition
period where CBD was prohibited,
lasted until four hours after
the conclusion of the fight.
And he was clearly
within that time period.
So you saw the contacted me and said,
hey,
you know,
technically Nate was in violation of this.
And I said,
hey,
look,
this was not the intent
of the rule of this is,
you know,
and they never indicated that
they were going to sanction him,
but I made it clear to say,
explain CBD for anybody that might
not know what we're talking about.
Sure.
So CBD part of the,
you know,
the marijuana plant but is
not psychoactive part of it.
Um,
I know a lot of our
fighters anecdotally use it,
um,
for anti-inflammatory PR purposes.
Um,
I think,
I mean,
have you ever used it or
what benefits is a anxiety?
It's,
it's great for people
that are under stress.
It,
uh,
it,
it actually has a great response for that.
I know a lot of people that
use it just for anxiety.
Um,
but anti-inflammation is,
is a big one.
That's the big one.
People use it for people with arthritis.
Love it.
Yeah.
Again,
comparing to,
you know,
a natural plant derived
product versus a synthetic,
you know,
nonsteroidal antiinflammatory
Advils Tylenol's can be toxic on.
Yeah.
Probably Common Sense.
Would would,
you know,
in addition to science would say that
the CBD is maybe a little bit healthier
for you.
Um,
nevertheless it was
prohibited in competition.
Is it still?
No.
So that was actually a rule change.
The water,
um,
prohibited list,
which we follow,
took it completely off.
The prohibited list started.
It's amazing.
2018 so that's great.
So we can just take CBD the entire time.
The training,
there's no,
it's obviously there's
no performance benefit,
there's no psychoactive effect.
It just reduces inflammation and
it doesn't have a natural way,
way healthier.
And it was the case before
they can do it in training.
It was only prohibited in competition.
So weigh in day and fight day.
Now it's completely been taken off the
list and it's okay to use it anytime.
That's fantastic.
So it was good.
So,
but we identified a problem with,
with the rules in that
when Nate finished that,
that fight with Conor,
you sought it,
came to the post fight medical tent said,
Nate,
we need to make a collection from you.
And I don't know whether
it was blood or urine,
but they got a sample from him.
He then went to the press
conference after and it was on,
you know,
took the CVD.
What I said is,
look,
you can't punish him.
You have the sample that
shows what was in his system.
Yes,
CBD was prohibited in competition,
but you have a sample to show
whether or not he was using it.
It's clear that you know,
he was using it after the fight.
We just put those extra four hours in
there with a thought of if a fight or
finishes a fight and somehow you
saw it as not able to get to him,
say gets in the ambulance right away.
It goes to the hospital.
You increase that window just
in case they can't get them.
Come to find out.
As we started putting
this program together,
you saw it.
It can always get to that fight
or after if they're transported,
they can hop in the ambulance with them
and it wasn't an issue where we needed
those extra four months.
So we changed that rule.
And now I'm basically,
the rule is the in competition period
ends with a collection immediately after
the fight or you know,
you saw it,
it has a reasonable amount
of time after the fight.
Um,
so the funny thing is,
uh,
after we changed this rule,
Nate and Nick Diaz come to
a fight and they're sitting,
call it the zoo for section,
you know,
Kinda Dana's section right
there behind Dana's table.
So I go over to nick and Nate and I said,
hey Nate,
man,
uh,
hey,
we changed that rule,
you know,
the whole CBD thing.
And actually we kind of refer to it as,
as the Nate Diaz rule.
And when the Diaz brothers ratified,
I mean it's pandemonium and chaos.
Everybody's yelling their
name and I literally,
I'm like,
I have the demon registered with them.
He didn't look at me,
he was looking somewhere else.
So about a month later,
Nate,
I see him,
I'm in,
I think it was in Vegas.
I'm in the kind of walk out
10 hole and here comes Nate.
So he sees me,
he comes over me,
gives
me kind of the bro Hug,
what's up,
he's with Yancey Mendez
and so against the,
and I started talking and Yancy beyond
being just an unbelievably entertaining
fighters.
One of the best dudes on the roster.
Great Guy.
So I'm talking against,
he all the sudden Nico's,
hey Jeff man,
tell Yancey about my usada rule.
I've got a sata rule named after me dog.
And so I thought,
man,
you're doing something right when Nate
Diaz is like excited about a change in
that you sought a rule,
right?
Yeah.
That is a,
that is a very good rule.
I'm really excited about that.
Um,
what's the story with neck?
He can't fight?
Is he still have like some sort of a,
so yeah,
Nicholas will,
nick was our first fire that
ran into the whereabouts issue.
So he got three whereabouts,
failures and a rolling 12 months.
So he's currently going
through that process.
You know,
it's a tough one cause
I don't want to fight.
I think he does.
I mean we've,
and I've sat down with him over the last
couple months and talking about trying
to resolve this whereabouts issue.
I mean the unfortunate thing there is
look the whereabouts failure sanctions are
meant to catch people that are
cheating and trying to avoid testing.
And I just think Nick's lifestyle led
to those three kind of whereabouts,
not that he was trying to avoid testing.
Um,
nick being nick,
we're trying.
Yeah,
we're trying to work through that.
He,
you know,
he put,
he trusted certain individuals
to do his whereabouts for him.
Um,
I think is what happened over time and
those individuals would come in and out
of his life and of course,
kind of unbeknownst to him that he
was missing a lot of these things,
never less,
you know,
the,
again,
there's strict liability here and
it's currently under sanction,
but we're hoping to resolve
that pretty quick now.
Uh,
last time we,
you were on,
you talked about this,
a new potential testosterone that was
derived from animals and that there might
be a way that people could take
this stuff and go undetected.
Yeah.
I mean,
I haven't heard much
about that since then.
Um,
was it just a theoretical?
No,
now it's out there.
It's real.
Um,
but you know,
again,
some of the things that to combat that
or the biological passport program where
you're looking over time,
it's somebody t ratio
and even though that,
you know,
won't trigger a positive on the
isotope ratio mass spectrometry,
if you see wild variances
and t ratios over time,
that could potentially trigger,
would there be a way to more violation,
sorry.
There was a way to mitigate that,
a biological passport thing by making a
specific time that you inject it every
day and doing it on a regular basis.
Like instead of,
I know,
um,
it was one of the ways that,
uh,
some fighters have gotten caught is
that they knew they were going to be in
Vegas or something for
a long period of time.
So they couldn't take any and they,
maybe we'd take it twice a week.
So they doubled their dose and took it
in a one shot and then they got hit with
a random and then it showed
that they had this massive,
yeah,
it's a potential.
I mean,
you know,
someone who has the resources
and sophisticated and
somebody has someone who's
educated in chemistry.
Um,
it's,
it's definitely a cat and
mouse game anti-doping.
And you know,
um,
Vogel talked about that
when he was on here.
I mean the,
the premise of ICARUS
initially it was right,
he was going to show that
that anti-doping doesn't work.
And it was actually something I was,
I watched your podcast with them
and watch the movie as well.
And initially I was a little bit turned
off on that premise cause he gave,
he gave the examples of Armstrong.
Marion Jones just said,
look,
anti-doping just doesn't work and I'm
going to go out and prove that that
doesn't make any sense.
If both those people
got busted that right.
That's the reality.
But look how they did.
They got busted through the investigative
element of anti-doping and that's
what's something that was learned and
came out of I think the investigations I
was involved in and all,
you know,
you started does this,
water does this.
The drug testing is not enough.
You know,
drug testing is a necessity.
You need to have that,
but you also need to have a
strong investigative element.
You have to liaison and you sought a
does this with law enforcement throughout
the world.
Um,
so that if you can't catch somebody
because they're sophisticated in the
techniques they're using,
you know,
maybe you catch them through,
informants or other
investigative resources.
Pressure.
Exactly.
Now that documentary blew my mind.
It was incredible.
For people who haven't seen it.
It's on Netflix,
it's called ICARUS.
It's by Bryan Fogel and the documentary.
The premise was he was a guy who was a,
a cyclist and decided to compete in a
race first clean and then come back and do
it again under the assistance of a guy
who was an expert in anti-doping that
showed him like,
what's the stuff that you should
take right along the line?
He makes friends with this Guy Gregory,
how do you say his last name?
Right.
Check off,
something like that.
Um,
and during this time period
it's discovered that the
entire Soviet Olympic team
is on steroids and that they
cheated during the games.
It's Sochi and he explains how they did
it and then the investigation comes down
and the guy has to flee Russia
and then he comes to America.
He goes into protective
custody and Bryan Fogel just,
you talk about like just stepping in shit.
Holy smokes.
Did he come across on many,
did an awesome job of telling the story
and this Gregory God and making him kind
of the sympathetic character.
Yet he was the kind of the evil villain
that was doing all this over in Russia
was just incredible.
A movie.
The one thing that he didn't
cover too much in the movie,
it was a little bit disappointed is
who really the true heroes were of that
whole thing.
So there was a husband and wife couple
the tally and Yuliya Stepanova and um,
Yulia was an 800 meter runner for Russia
and Vitaly actually worked for Rosado.
The Russian anti-doping organization has
a drug collecting officer and they were
the ones basically that caused this German
documentary to come out exposing what
Gregory was doing.
And then at that of time the heat came
on Gregory because this information was
out there and he was either forced to
stay there and likely be,
you know,
arrested and put the blame on or flee,
um,
to the u s it was dealt with
very briefly in that movie.
But those two I think were
the true heroes because,
you know,
they just did this cause it
was the right thing to do.
Um,
Gregory did it,
you know,
obviously with a lot of self preservation
in mind and that he had one of two
choices.
Either take off and come clean or
stay there and face the consequences.
But never less man.
Fogel did.
I thought an awesome job in that movie.
And just an incredible,
incredible story.
And it's,
it's really,
um,
you know,
tough,
I'm sure for Olympic athletes to say,
God,
man,
this is what,
what we're up against when you're talking
about state sponsored doping and the
KGB being involved.
And there's almost a sense of
hopelessness out there that,
you know,
how am I ever know that
I'm as a clean athlete,
you know,
my rights are going to be protected.
Again,
going back to what we're
doing with the UFC,
the beauty of what we're doing is you,
you can never see that because
you have an independent authority.
You sorta who's operating and
administering our program.
Um,
so unlike the Russian government where
they have interest of Russian athletes,
you know,
doing well and winning gold medals,
you saw it.
I could,
you know,
in a sense,
give a crap about,
you know,
who's being,
who's being caught and isn't.
Um,
so one of the things that came up in the
film that was really disturbing was the
collusion between water and
the IOC and that they really,
it was in their best interest
to not sanction Russia.
Yeah,
it's a con.
You have people sitting,
you still do on the,
on the water board and on the IOC board.
So there's,
there's a conflict of interest is
wada is going to come in and say,
hey this was clearly
state sponsored doping.
We're going to exclude Russia
from the Olympics for the next,
you know,
however many years.
Well that's a hit to the IOC cause IOC
is getting money from these television
networks putting on the Games
in Seoul or in Tokyo coming up.
So you know,
a conflict of interest there.
You saw it as a nonprofit organization.
So the UFC,
the UFC does pay them to
administer our program,
but it's not lining
the pockets of anybody.
They're CEOs not making more
money because of the UFC is here.
They maybe have a few more
personnel to administer the program,
but you know,
if,
if we go away,
you saw is still in existence.
They're still doing Olympic
testing and you know,
nobody's pocket books are hurting.
Yeah.
That independence I think is critical.
And that's something that
you brought up earlier.
I think that's so awesome.
And you know what a
massive credit to the UFC,
they decided to do it this
way and not do it in house.
Just take on your protocol
out of courage to do that.
And it takes a real commitment
to try to clean up the sport.
Um,
one of the things that was really
weird was like they banned some,
some teams from Russia,
like not all the sports but the sports
they band where like nobody gives a fuck
about what,
what the sports wear.
Yeah.
Well I think in reality
you could find out what,
what they banned,
they were going to ban the team,
but the outrage from
that was just so strong.
And then they realize the economic
impact of that would be literally in the
billions of dollars.
But think they abandoned
track and field team from,
from Rio Games,
which is pretty significant track and
field being a pretty big Olympic sport.
There was a new hair,
Russia banned from Winter Olympics,
but clean athletes can compete.
So this is new,
right?
Russia athletes make that a little
bigger for my fucking shitty eyes.
It Russia has been banned from the 2018
winter Olympics in South Korea over the
country.
Systematic manipulation
of anti-doping rules.
However,
Russian athletes who can prove,
prove that they are clean,
we'll be invited in in quotes to compete
in say that Pyong Chang Look at Jamie
was degree in Korean.
Uh,
the International Olympic
Committee said Tuesday,
so that's fascinating.
So they'll,
they'll be literally competing
under the Olympic flag,
which is like woo.
It's the most wide ranging punishment
ever met it out by the IOC in a party on a
participating nation,
let alone a powerhouse
of the Olympic movement.
Yeah,
I mean,
you're competing on the Olympic flag,
but everybody's still gonna know the
commentators are going still gonna say the
Russian athletes competing
on the Olympic flag.
That's bizarre.
Right?
Competing,
I mean,
is this unprecedented?
Someone competing under the Olympic flag?
I'm not sure whether it's happened before.
Not Man.
How's it?
I'm pretty sure I remember
just random people.
I don't,
they might not have had to country to
perform or their whole country might not
have sent them,
but they would qualify or something.
Okay.
Wow.
Crazy.
Um,
but there was also a
certain teams that were,
were kicked out of,
or certain gold metals
that were a rescinded,
but that was the other thing
that I thought was really
interesting about you saw
it as,
um,
protocol is that they freeze samples.
So just in case the testing
improves in the future,
he used to turn again,
it,
you know,
there's no denying it's a cat and
mouse game going on out there,
but a deterrent is that
it's not all of them,
but certain samples can
be frozen up to 10 years.
And as new tests come online,
like the longterm metabolite tests that,
uh,
Gregory developed after five or six years,
they may go back and retest those samples.
And you know,
when we go out and educate our athletes,
I tell them,
look,
maybe you're not in the UFC anymore,
but your legacies around
forever and you know,
that's a smear to your legacy forever.
And it's all about creating that.
My job,
I worked for the UFC,
my job is not,
hey,
let's see how many athletes we can catch.
My job is to try to get out there,
educate,
develop relationships,
and create that deterrent saying,
look,
you don't want to do this.
It's going to catch you eventually.
If you're going to do something,
I'll give you every resource
and bit of knowledge.
I have to make sure you're
successful under the program.
But you know,
success in my eyes is
very few positive tests.
I don't,
you know,
right on the Kuwait,
the program with success
because we've had,
you know,
60 or so positives over time.
I'd love to see,
you know,
none and see more of that.
Those graph showing those,
you know,
common
markers of a,
of a doper come more into line.
Right.
You're not in the position of a
detective or a prosecutor anymore.
Your position is now an athlete liaison.
It is,
and it's,
it's a much different role.
There's a role I'd really,
I'd really enjoy.
It's probably a lot less stressful.
Definitely a lot stressful,
a lot less stressful.
And you know,
Dana says it all the time,
the importance level in the
UFC and MMA is off the charts.
I,
I still have a strong belief in
ethics and sports and beliefs.
Sports are so good for kids
and teaching them life lessons.
It transcends sports.
My,
I have three daughters that,
you know,
played sports growing up.
A couple of them still do.
And I know when they get out into the
real world and that work environment,
there's nothing,
they can't handle it because
they've already handled it.
And Sports,
they've run up against a
coach who's an asshole.
They'd run up against
teammates that are selfish.
They've had great,
you know,
occurrences when they've
worked well as a team.
All of that is going to come into
play to help them in their lives.
And when you introduce
something and something,
it's so pure and good
that's breaking the rules.
Um,
that short term mostly longterm
is not healthy for your sports,
is about to be healthy for you.
And at some level,
especially the way these performance
enhancing drugs are used,
they're not really
being used in a healthy,
healthy manner.
And,
um,
so yeah,
but I feel,
I feel very strongly and very positive
about what we're doing and the role that
I'm playing here.
Well,
it's interesting that the UFC,
unlike a lot of sports,
the,
the history is pretty transparent
and the history of doping is also
pretransplant.
Like everybody's really aware of
what the wild west days where like,
I mean,
it's,
people talk about it,
they laugh about it.
It's,
it's sort of an,
it's not a secret at all in particular
as we were saying about pride.
Um,
but you know,
I think that ultimately
what sports should be about,
it should be about effort,
skill,
determination,
focus,
discipline.
And those are the lessons
that you could pass on.
Not who has the best pharmacist,
not,
you know,
not who has the best team of scientists
that can hide the results better.
And that's one of the more
disturbing things about it.
Gris or,
or,
or any of these other
things that have shown that,
you know,
there's systematic anti-doping or
are doping or state sponsored doping.
It's just,
it distorts the whole thing.
Like what a victory is or
why you've got some athletes,
it probably would have won
anyway if everybody was clean.
They might've been the best athlete
anyway and then they could have one.
Floyd Landis told me,
told me that all the time about lance,
he said that dude was the baddest ass
bicycle rider ever and take away all the
drugs that were taken in the sport.
He would have been the best writer ever.
He had something going on there,
but the reality was everybody
was using something men.
That's how fucked up sport.
Yeah.
I think I talked about this last time,
but I really,
you know,
people are surprised to hear this,
but I had a lot of compassion
and understanding for a
lot of these dopers after
they told me their stories.
I mean,
you're a young kid,
vulnerable kid that you know,
wasn't really worldly,
that all your teenage life,
you
aspire to go over to Europe and get on a
bike and compete and he's awesome races
and all of a sudden you're over there,
dropped off in a coach,
sitting in a room says you
want to stay here a kid.
Here's the program that were on Meth.
I heard one,
I heard a dozen of those stories,
grown men crying,
retelling those stories.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean I feel good about,
you know,
change in the culture
in this sport radically.
I would love to have a podcast with you
and lance sit down together and discuss
this now that the dust has
kind of settled and you know,
he's been pretty open about
it and transparent about
the whole process himself.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think the difference,
the difference that that he
has with everybody else is,
you know,
again,
this is back to [inaudible] contention
that they didn't catch lance is you look
back at his history and they did actually,
you know,
in 99 I think he had a
corticosteroid positive in 2001.
I think he had a test that showed,
um,
high likelihood of EPL use
that wasn't followed on.
But what he did is he became very powerful
in the sport and the International
Cycling Union was,
was corrupt and basically use that
power and wield it and they cover it up.
Um,
a lot of those tests
crazy.
It is crazy.
And it's a,
and the crazy thing about combat sports
is that we're not just talking about
crossing a finish line quicker.
We're talking about the ability to
deliver more damage on your opponent.
And that's why it's so critical
that people fight clean,
whole new level.
It's a completely different thing.
There's just really,
there's no comparison.
Now let's get into,
we briefly touched on weight cutting.
Um,
but I know that the UFC has
recognized that there's,
there's a real issue and,
um,
what steps have we taken to try to
mitigate the problems that are caused by
weight cutting?
Yeah,
it's interesting.
And another one of the reasons why I
love the performance institute and the
staff that we had there
and that before them.
And it really stemmed from the Usada
program where under the Wada Code you
banned the use of Ivs.
And so,
cause I was kind of the point person
obviously explained why ivy's or you know,
it goes back to the,
to the cyclist,
they were using ivs to basically flush
their system of drugs to manipulate their
bicycle biological passport.
So if their blood doping
or using EPO and um,
it would have a tendency
to lower those and,
and normalize those
biological passport levels.
And so a lot of learn that through
some of the investigations that,
you know,
they were conducted and
determined that ivy use,
um,
in excess of 50 milliliters,
every six hours would be prohibited.
So when we announced that we were
adopting the water prohibited list and
prohibited methods,
um,
there was some,
some blow back within
the UFC community saying,
hey,
these things are used regularly because
fighters are pushing themselves to the
edge to make weight and do you
understand what you're doing here?
You're going to put fighters and unsafe
positions where they're going to get in
and not be,
um,
rehydrated.
So we took a look at
that and spoke with you,
saw it,
and he said,
hey,
you know,
maybe we should,
slowly rolled out the ivy band.
So we actually delayed
that by three months.
The program went into effect July
1st and we instituted the IB band,
um,
October 1st.
So we had three months of
getting fighters prepared for it,
educating them why,
um,
that they were banned.
Nevertheless,
I mean,
real quickly the whole weight cutting
issue came kind of into my plate.
And while,
you know,
I wasn't an expert in it,
I had to get out and talk
to a lot of fighters,
camps,
coaches about ivs and give them,
you know,
alternatives to rehydrating the right way.
And so I,
again,
not being an expert myself,
I reached out to what I found
were we're experts in the world.
A certain guy by name of Doctor Robert
[inaudible] who is a phd exercise
physiologist,
works with the US Army Research Institute
of Environmental Medicine Studies,
environmental effects on soldiers,
his expertise being dehydration.
So soldiers in the Middle East
that are marching for hours,
days upon a time run out of water,
dehydrate themselves.
How do we get these fighters back?
Are these soldiers back rehydrated
and back into the fight and thought,
hey,
this is the type of expert
that we need to talk to.
Its extreme dehydration.
Not,
you know,
some kid that has diarrhea,
it's mildly dehydrated with some,
some pedialyte.
So we brought him in.
Um,
had him actually the week of UFC 200,
um,
he was in town,
got a chance to talk to a lot of the,
the fighters coming in and analyze
the message they were using.
Um,
he recommended to us,
hey,
you know,
here's the maximum amount
of weight fighters,
you know,
that you should recommend.
Fighters are losing that fight week.
And that's how we came up with
our weight guideline of 8%.
So we recommend when those fighters
checkin Tuesday for a Saturday fight there
within 8% of their goal weight,
usually on Friday.
I'm not a requirement or recommendation,
but you know,
we put that out there and
educated heavily on that.
Um,
since then,
uh,
you talked,
I think last week about Andy Foster,
the executive director of California
who's really taken the lead in terms of
commissions on combating
dangerous weight cutting.
Um,
he worked with US pretty closely
on developing his 10 point,
um,
weight cutting plan or plan to
combat serious weight cutting.
Um,
includes his commission making calls
to fighters on the car 30 days out,
10 days out,
making them a little bit more accountable,
uh,
farther out than fight week.
Um,
he's also got a provision
where fight night,
he takes the fighters weight,
weighs them and their recommendation is
you only put on 10% of your weight back
on plus a pound.
Um,
if they're over that California can
recommend the fight or move up away class.
Um,
so really,
yeah,
I mean just a lot of,
you know,
education recommendations not here.
A lot of people talk about,
and I'm curious for your thoughts on this.
Hey we can,
we can stop instantaneous issue and
instantaneously just put rules out there.
If you lose this much weight or
put this much weight back on,
you're suspended for six months,
12 months,
you know,
whatever your,
we're just not going to let you,
you fight.
My concern there is when
you have absolute rules,
fighter's going to do
everything possible to you know,
to make weight.
Say you had a rule that if you miss,
wait,
you can't fight it again for 12 months,
you have to move up a weight class
fighter's going to kill themselves to make
weight.
My fear would be that you,
you put an absolute rule out there and
someone get hurts because of the rule
that you put in place,
which is a,
you know,
I think it's a measured approach.
You have to continually reevaluate it.
But I think right now the rules that are
out there between our recommendations,
California has rules are more
guideline recommendations.
And then that in conjunction with what
we're doing at the performance institute
where,
I mean you saw last week,
there is no excuse if you have issues
making weight or you're not sure what your
weight class is,
that you have every resource available
the best in the world to you to come in
and find that out,
to be given a plan on how
to safely then make weight.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's,
it's a multimillion dollar investment
that the UFC has put I think toward that
problem and you know,
hey,
maybe two,
three years from now we say,
hey,
that was with good intentions,
but not enough.
We need to do more.
But I think right now,
um,
that's our strategy,
uh,
on the issue.
Well,
I think a couple things would have to
happen to really stop weight cutting.
One thing you're going to have to blow
up these weight classes because there's
going to be champions in these weight
classes that really won't be in that
weight class anymore.
If you cut all the real heavy duty
weight cutting out of the picture.
I think what one FC is
trying to do is they're,
they're doing hydration test
and they do a series of them.
I believe they do three
leading up to the fight,
which really was it.
Benevidez was telling me this,
someone,
someone was telling me this,
that they've essentially made it almost
impossible for you to cut weight.
So they do hydration test on weighing
at the way they're doing hydration test
three different times,
three different times
leading up to the fight.
I don't know the exact protocol,
but what they've done is essentially
made it so that you can't be dehydrated.
Like you can't,
when you weigh in,
you have to weigh in and as you know,
like if you're fighting at
one 70 but you know you,
you get on the scale and
you're fucking dying,
they're like,
no,
you're not really one 70 like,
and that,
that's really where it should be.
This idea that the best way to fight is
to cheat and to drain all yourself of
fluids and then pretend
that you're 160 pounds,
then get back on the scale,
you know,
15 hours later at one
85 that's fucking crazy.
That doesn't make any sense.
You're not really 160 pound fighter.
You're 185 pound fighter who almost died.
Yeah,
it's interesting,
you know,
if I talk with forest a lot about this
because he went through it and again why
he's such a great asset to
the probe to the company,
uh,
but he says,
look,
there's certain and girls
that have a genetic,
um,
ability to,
to carry,
you know,
they have good muscle mass.
Usually that just carry a
ton of water and it's not,
it's not difficult.
It's not dangerous for them to
drop 10 or 15 pounds and not,
but it would be if they
fought 15 pounds under c,
if they're a fighting at 170 pounds,
they really weigh one 85 and if they
cut down to one 70 they make that weight
and then fought right then.
Then it would be dangerous.
Their performance would
be radically diminished.
So we're lying.
When those people get on the scale,
when they get on the scale and they flex
and they say one 70 sure you're one 70
for about an hour,
you know,
and then you're going to go right back
up to what you were before you dehydrated
yourself.
This is madness to me.
Well this goes against what
fighting is supposed to be.
What we talked about before
about discipline and focus
and and and technique and
training.
That's what competing
is supposed to be about.
It's supposed to be about a fight or
two equally skillful individuals try to
figure out who's got the best strategy
and who's got the best we'll and
technique.
It's not supposed to be about who can
do this legal cheating thing best cause.
That's what weight cutting is.
Well you know,
really the modern history of the UFC and
the reason I think it's so successful
is the Renzo and Dana
ran toward regulation,
right?
Yes.
They said,
hey,
this is a no,
you know,
marketed as an no rules,
no hold bar event.
They ran toward rules.
And so I think you know
what you're taught.
And I actually had a discussion with Bob
Bennett about this executive director
of Nevada.
He's Graham last week and you know,
he's looking what
California is doing says,
look,
we have physicals after the way in.
So you know,
we do the way it is now at the host hotel.
So it's usually done
at a ballroom fighter,
gets up on the scale,
makes weight immediately,
goes behind the curtain and
has their pre-fight physical.
Right.
But do they have a hydration test?
I,
they don't.
I know California does some
hydration testing fight night,
but would,
Bob told me as I have the most experience,
ringside physicians in the world that
have seen more combat sports events and
everywhere,
I'm comfortable that these guys are
evaluating these medical professionals or
evaluating these fighters in the scenario
and if they feel or see something's
not safe for that fighter
to compete the next night,
that they'll call them off.
I think that's wonderful.
But I think all that does is keep fighters
from getting to the point of death.
I mean,
getting to the point where
they're sick and tear,
they're definitely compromised
when they're making the weight.
They're not really at that weight.
What I would really love,
in a perfect world,
besides the bare knuckle thing,
what I would really love is a
weight class every 10 pounds.
Just have every time.
I mean,
there's just giant gaps.
The gap between 85 and two
oh five is 20 fucking pounds.
That's a lot of weight.
I hear that.
But let me give you a scenario where it
shows that alone and can work female new
division for the UFC one 25 right?
Because we had a one
15 to one 35 pound gap,
right?
What happened in our
first championship fight?
So Jara Eubanks couldn't make weight.
She didn't,
she
wasn't even,
you know,
so there,
that in and of itself,
just making a weight class,
I don't think solves the problem.
But she's also relatively
inexperienced young to sport.
And this is a brand new way class
that they really didn't have a,
I'm not saying he had more weight classes,
wouldn't help,
but they're not going
to help by themselves.
You gotta it's gotta be
a multiple prong attack.
I think the hydration test
should be along with that,
the hydration test and weight classes
every 10 pounds and then give the champion
the benefit of the doubt.
Like whoever is the champion,
each division,
whatever,
whatever weight class,
you know what we find out what they
really way and they have an opportunity to
fight for the title in that weight class.
You have to,
I think we talked about it
when you tour through the Pie,
but we have on a couple of occasion use
that bioelectrical impedance machine to
determine is that the proper term?
I don't know.
Um,
but it basically can you
step on the scale and you,
you hold onto these handles and it gives
you some type of hydration reading.
Um,
we've done that a few
times on checking day,
weigh in day.
We're not sure exactly
what the numbers look like,
but that's something that,
you know,
we're looking into.
Clint also does a lot of
specific gravity testing,
fight week on fighters where,
you know,
it'll be a Tuesday or Wednesday and
I think he showed you that chart.
Um,
he'll look at how much weight fighter
has to lose and then look at what their
specific gravity reading is,
how diluted or concentrated the urine is.
And you know,
if you see someone with a bunch
of weight to lose that is,
you know,
relatively dehydrated
specific gravity wise,
then you know,
it can alter their plan.
So yeah,
I mean we've got a lot of,
a lot of that stuff going on.
I don't necessarily disagree with
you that that more needs to be done,
but right now our plan of attack
is to use these resources,
use the facility of the pie.
You know,
in an ideal world,
I think rather than making
these absolute rules,
trying to educate our fighters,
trying to show them,
I tell you one thing,
you can talk until you're blue in
the face about things being bad,
unhealthy for a fighter.
They're like,
I'm bullet proof.
Not only that,
they're fighters,
they're fighting.
That's bad for you anyway.
Right?
Like,
oh,
cut and weights bad for me too.
Okay.
Where they start listening.
And I think this is where the performance
institute comes into play when you
start talking about the
effect on your performance.
Um,
so if you tell them,
hey look,
if you can come to you know,
your proper weight in a more measured
approach and not lose a whole bunch and
put that what look,
look at the difference it's going to
make on your performance 24 to 30 hours
later because you see this,
I mean you see this occasionally
when fighters go through,
you know,
tough weight cuts.
You see them,
Sandra says after a round or two,
right?
Oh good.
He's looked moving up to 170 pounds.
I mean it's just phenomenal.
I also think now it's interesting,
there's,
you know,
on one side of it the criticism would be,
well you're just encouraging even
greater weight cuts and regains.
But I think this morning
weigh in thing that we've,
we've put together I think has had a
positive impact in a couple of areas.
Explain that for people to
know what we're talking about.
So actually Andy Foster again,
California before UFC one
99 came to me and said,
hey,
we've been doing this morning weigh
in for a couple regional local shows.
Would you guys be interested in it?
Where we do it at the host hotel,
we do it,
you know,
we'd open the scales from 9:00 AM to
11:00 AM and the idea would be a fighter
gets on weight in their hotel room,
upstairs hops on the
elevator steps on the scale.
They make weight,
they can start eating and drinking again
right away with the idea of they don't
have to wait til 4:00 PM and extra
know exactly what the idea of,
I think one of the dangers of,
you know,
weight cutting and being dehydrated is
the amount of time that you're at a,
you know,
add a loss of that water.
And in the past when we'd have
the weigh ins at an arena,
it would be,
the fight would have
to check in downstairs.
Say the,
we had the way ends at
four o'clock in an arena,
the firewood,
the fighter would check in
downstairs that maybe two,
um,
two 30 the bus would leave.
I remember in Rio were in one
time on a bus for an hour,
hour and a half to the arena.
Everybody's depleted and dehydrated on
the bus ride you step on a scale and a
cold,
you know,
environmentally unfriendly arena.
You then get back on the
bus drive another hour,
hour and a half.
You're talking multiple hours where
these fighters are in a depleted state.
So I think the morning way
and protects against that.
I think the other benefit
we've seen out of it,
I think it's more of a longterm than a
short term benefit is we've seen a lot
more fighters missing weight since
we went to the morning weigh ins.
And I think that's a product of timing.
And that in the past you had four,
you know,
four or five in the afternoon,
you had all day long to cut weight and
you would see fighters at 10 or 11 said,
I can't do anymore.
And a one or two o'clock I said,
no,
I can do a couple more pounds
and just all day long now,
unless you're literally not
sleeping the night before you fight,
you have a shorter window
in the morning to do that.
And I think a lot of those myths,
weights has helped identify those
fighters that I'm probably on the right,
the wrong weight class.
I can't make that weight of waking up,
you know,
five or six in the morning,
a couple hours,
and it's probably too much weight to lose.
And we've seen some fighters move
up in weight class because of that.
We've also seen some
fighters that have decided,
hey,
I gotta take this more professionally
and hire a nutritionist.
Like could be,
it could be a number of Madoff who made
weight easily for his last fight and the
fight before that obviously fell out of
the fight because his body shut down and
he had to go to the hospital.
It'd be rehydrated.
Yeah,
I mean I again,
I don't think it's a one
size fits all solution.
You have to be careful,
hey,
it'd be missed weight that
last time went to the hospital.
You know,
a knee jerk reaction would be you,
you can't fight this weight anymore.
What we saw this time,
he just changed the way he did things.
He came in,
he was on wait the night before,
he had a couple of pounds
to lose fight week.
So it can be done.
And again,
that reverts back to the
performance institute.
I think there's no excuse now that if
you're a new fighter and you're not making
a hell of a lot of money and
don't have the resources to hire,
you know,
George Lockhart who ever,
have Clinton Wattenberg who's an ivy
league educated Sports Dietitian that can
provide you all that remotely.
If you can't get to Vegas,
he'll give you a full plan over,
you know,
over the phone,
over email.
Um,
if you can get to Vegas,
not only will Clint
plan things out for you,
but you have a kitchen and cooks and
staff that will provide you that meal
throughout your whole fight camp
that just want to be there for free.
So amazing.
The place is incredible.
And we will have a Clint and um,
Dunkin,
uh,
on the podcast.
Explain all that.
What's in that little silver?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
this is,
so one of the things that,
that we want to do with
this program again is,
you know,
first and foremost,
it's to protect the UFC athlete,
protect the rights of clean athletes,
but we also want to influence other
sports influenced anti-doping as a whole.
So you saw came to us
earlier this year and said,
we've got some new technology.
What do you guys think about using your
program to be the first to kind of roll
it out?
And so the answer was,
well,
is the science good?
Is it validated?
They said,
yeah,
it is.
Um,
I was actually at a,
at a conference mid summer back in New
York and sat on a panel with Major League
Baseball Pga tour and the UFC and a
bunch of anti-doping scientists there.
And they were talking about this
technology and the other leagues.
We're asked,
hey,
you guys gonna Institute that?
And they're like,
Nah.
Um,
you know,
I don't,
I don't think enough
stare and they went to me.
I'm like,
absolutely.
If you saw the science tells me this,
this works.
We want to be the first,
especially if it's more convenient
and more efficient for our program.
So what this is,
is it's a leaching device and um,
you know,
until this came out basically to
get any blood tests from a shit,
you got some scissors.
I,
yeah.
Nice.
That was ready for you
and tell this came out.
Basically any blood tests done from,
uh,
from our athlete had to be
done with the phlebotomist.
The full on needle in the
vein take out a vial of blood.
So with this leaching device,
it's got 30 micro needles in it.
The size about eyelash,
you put it up on your arm,
you hit this button and painlessly
the microneedles reach into just the
capillary.
So just the blood of the top of the,
uh,
of the skin and draw out
a small amount of blood.
And this,
this light turns red.
When that blood's drawn out.
Whoa.
The blood is then deposited onto a,
an index card.
It's called dried blood spot testing.
So a drop or two of blood
on the four corners,
the cards then sealed up,
placed in the mail and
sent to a water laboratory.
This is all have to be
done on video so that no,
well you have a color.
It's not the athlete doing themselves
can have a collector doing that.
I mean,
that could be the future where an
athlete is doing it themselves,
but then facetime or something.
Exactly.
But,
but here are the benefits of that a,
and this is,
this is huge for me.
I want to make things as convenient
for our athletes as possible.
So,
you know,
you talked to our roster and ask them,
would you prefer big needle stuck in the
vein of your arm and a of blood taken
out versus completely painless,
um,
you know,
leach of some blood from your capillaries.
They're all gonna say,
obviously this,
you talk about cost.
So,
uh,
blood taken out of a vein in
your arm requires a phlebotomist.
So in those cases where you
saw it as doing a blood test,
they usually take a drug collection
officer and a phlebotomist to take out of
the blood to take out the blood.
I mean that's,
that's a couple hundred dollars there.
Um,
a vial of blood needs to be cold
shipped to the water laboratories.
Here you're talking about dried blood
on an index card that just needs to be
sealed up.
It becomes tamper proof once it is
and put it in the mail for 55 cents.
Wow.
Um,
so I think incredible efficiency,
convenience to the
athlete for our program.
And again,
we want to lead and I think,
you know,
when you talk about a master's question
regularly about local or regional,
and then may show saying,
hey,
this is great what you guys
are doing for your program,
but how much does this program costs you?
And it is a multimillion
dollar program in a year.
And they say,
Hey,
we love to do something like that,
but you know,
we can't afford that.
Something like this where now you cut
your costs down from sending blood to,
you know,
for maybe thousand dollars to,
maybe a hundred dollars,
this device in one DCL going to
collect it out and put it on a card.
I think it has some
really great implications,
not just for the UFC,
but you know,
throughout the sport.
Can I see that thing?
Sure.
It was pretty bad ass.
Wow.
Incredible.
Um,
anything else?
Should we wrap this up?
We're good.
Yeah,
man.
I think I'm good.
Unless you got anything
else doing an amazing job.
I mean,
it's just,
it's incredible.
The results.
It's a,
it's so cool to see the results on
the biological passport that you get.
You guys could show it in a chart and,
um,
I mean it pretty much everyone agrees.
I mean,
it's just,
it's really changed
the nature of fighting.
It really has,
it changed the sport.
It changed.
It's almost eliminated doping.
Yeah.
I really appreciate it.
As I told you,
I really appreciate the
platform you have here.
Literally every fighter
in and camp and manager,
you know,
on our roster watches this.
So it'd be able to get in
and talk about these things.
Talk about that new technology.
We just use that actually I think rose
Nama Junis was the first fight or that
you sought to try that out on,
so a center tax tactical.
Hey rose,
I heard they,
they did the leaching
device and the blood,
the dried blood spot tests.
Would you think she said awesome.
It didn't feel a thing and she said,
my mind is blown by the tech how far
technology's come here and that's a big
part of anti-doping and that deterrent
when you're now saying look at how the
technology is evolving here and
you get an athlete that thinks,
well you know I think I can out
with them or out cat and mouse them.
They see shit like this that are going
to think and perceptions almost as
important as reality and a lot of these
occasions and they start seeing things
like this and that deterrent factors
built up I think higher and higher.
Yeah.
It seems like at one point in time there
was a race and the dopers we're just
like one half step ahead.
But now it seems like it's even,
and with the possibility of freezing your
sample and then looking towards it to
the future,
it's not worth it.
Yeah.
I don't know if I call it even yet,
but that goes is definitely
narrowing and you're,
you're affecting the way that
dopers are doping these days.
I think you know,
now the,
the,
you know microdosing I
think is big and it's,
it's difficult to catch microdosing but
you've altered the behavior of the doper
from taking drugs really unabated to
very small amounts of the benefits aren't
going to be as great.
I think you got to consider
that a win for anti doping.
I think that gap continues to,
to narrow and when they
microdose like what,
what it like say would that be like
testosterone or something like that?
Testosterone Epo.
Probably the two most common vary how
much of a window of detection matter of
hours,
hours.
But you know,
again,
going back to,
I think I might've told this
story last time I was on,
but the Floyd Landis Lance days,
they were manipulating during the
Tour de France and eight hour window.
So from 10:00 PM to 6:00 AM they
wouldn't test them during the tour of the
thought was these guys are racing
up side of the mountain for five,
six hours a day.
We got to let these guys sleep.
And they figured out,
hey,
if we do something at 10 oh one by 601
there are list of tests or can come.
It'd be clear.
Um,
so you know,
yeah,
that prospect's all is out there.
That's why the UFC program,
there's no limits on the test now.
Right.
It's just a bummer.
It's in terms of their sleep side is,
yeah,
it's brutal.
But I think,
you know,
I think most appreciate that that's,
that's the price of,
you know,
clean sport and tried to ensure,
would there be a way to change that?
Like would there be some
sort of a wearable device
that would detect changes in
your body?
I've often thought that.
How about a wearable device?
It was top secret.
They collected everything 24 hours a day
that you peel it off after a couple of
weeks and it's,
and it's tested or give
them the wearable device.
So when they're sleeping,
so you don't interrupt our sleep cycles.
So 10:00 PM to 8:00 AM or whatever it is
that you decide it would be the window
that they need to sleep.
While they're doing that,
they must have this device on that
detects any changes to their metabolism,
any changes in input,
and then they can't eat while they're on.
This is we,
believe me,
the anti-doping community is
always thinking about things.
I talked to Travis Tygart,
the CEO of Usada last week,
and he,
you know,
he made it clear and that you saw that
I think dedicates $3 million a year
grants toward research and anti-doping,
things like that.
So I mean that,
that race is always going
on and is always continuing.
Beautiful.
Great work.
Mr Novitsky,
I'm sorry about the nickname.
Oh,
get over it.
You're okay with us right off the bat.
Beautiful.
Thanks brother.
Appreciate it,
man.
All right.